I have some new tour dates to announce I
will be in uh Phoenix Arizona on April
30th at Arizona Financial theater
uh that'll be the biggest show I've ever
done now
uh Austin Texas on June 10th at the Bass
Concert Hall Guilford New Hampshire June
20th July 20th I'm sorry at the Bank of
New Hampshire Pavilion
and uh Windsor Ontario Ontario on August
18th at the Coliseum at Caesars Windsor
and Niagara Falls Ontario on August 20th
at the Fallsview Casino those tickets
are available now get all your tickets
at theovan.com
t-o-u-r thank you for getting tickets
through there and nowhere else praise
God
we got new merch check out that root
beer hoodie if you want that ice cold
hitter baby you want that one that just
damn
God
it puts Antarctica in your throat
and that four piece enamel pin set check
them all out and thank you for the love
at theovanstore.com
today's guest is an Entertainer uh he's
a
he's that ravioli baby you know he's um
he's everything dude he's he's a damn
he's super Mario's second cousin who
runs a bakery low key
you know what I'm saying he's that
beautiful man in Italian and we're going
to learn more about him you know him
from Barstool uh as the um he's that
side slurper that lactose uh monkey on
the edge of uh Sunday conversations and
he is also uh the host of his uh only
Stan's show reinterviews only fans
content creators
um this is our first time really getting
to know each other I'm grateful for his
time today's guest is Glennie balls
[Music]
my story
back
[Applause]
balls baby good to see you man I'm very
excited to be here this is exciting yeah
is it so people say Glenny they say
balls what are they uh balls dude it's a
lot of Glennie it's a lot of Glennie I
prefer balls people call me Mr Balls I
like that I've got a lot of glenderman
balls it's very easy word to play on
glenor balls but I kind of like balls
yeah yeah I grew up with Glenn though so
I'm still getting used to Glennie really
so Glenn is are you a family name are
you like a ball is the fifth or
something oh my dad's name is Glenn
actually my all my dad and his brothers
are all geez Greg Gary and Glenn so I'm
a junior oh wow so you um and is that is
that like a tradition what kind of
family are you guys Italian you guys are
Italian I think it's necessarily a
tradition though yeah but I don't know
maybe maybe my grandparents just said
[__] it we're all gonna do geez my
grandpa's name was Greg too so then my
Uncle Greg was a junior it's all geez a
lot of G's yeah it's a g thing oh I like
that yeah and I wonder if G is like a
power letter or something
um what's a good power letter like if
you had to run in a room and like say
there's a fire or something right I
would say m
um yeah something about it right in the
middle yeah don't worry I'll get us the
rest of the way something like that M
kind of when you get through the
alphabet you're like J K L you're like
shit's getting weird and you're like m
H off the top of my head I'm saying M
like a t a t feels strong to me yeah t
feels pretty strong doesn't it yeah
because it also has that look we're like
okay you can put something on top of me
I got this m kind of has like four legs
almost you're like we're gonna get there
100 B's got the tits though why because
yeah it looks like two tits but B
doesn't do it for me I feel like I want
like a big straight line like a t on top
or that um
quiet um domey thing like the a has
yeah the a is kind of a is like uh I
can't lie look at G and I think of G is
kind of a beta letter g p
y u none of those seem good to me Y is
definitely
um
yeah what it almost seems like at the
end of the alphabet things got very like
they didn't know what things got a
little I don't want to say trans at the
end of the alphabet but it got very like
we're doing something's happening they
just kind of said [__] it nothing
there's five straight consonants yeah
five concerts you don't want to see five
straight consonants
yeah they did man
um what's going on man good to see you
bro yeah I'm excited I don't think I've
seen you in a while well that was last
time I saw you at that uh Titans game
right oh yeah yeah dude yeah we were you
guys were in the like a sweet box or
something yeah I think it's like I guess
it's like the influencer suite they have
there yeah which feels weird to say well
they had anybody that was an influencer
to there and it was in Tennessee and so
you have anybody that like people that
like you have somebody from Remington
Shotgun you know you have very much like
you know you have like people that deal
with 4-H and Animalia in there you have
like um country singer you know it's it
has more of a southern kind of Western
gamut they have out there yeah I think
that they like the VP Hattie B's was in
there I think Gary Clark Jr was in there
that day it was Gary Clark Jr he's a
like a Blues singer oh really yeah I
think Guy Clark Jr was there hmm I was
too intimidated say hi to him but I
think it was Guy Clark Jr oh I think he
was yeah he was sitting at the table to
the right with his Pals yes yes you're
probably wondering who it was because he
has that Vibe yeah that that's someone
yeah and I finally figured I was Gary
Clark Jr but he seemed like they didn't
want to be bothered so I didn't go talk
to him yeah I couldn't tell if it was
like sitting maybe like Sidney Poitier
or if it was um
maybe
um Leon Kravitz or whatever you know so
I didn't know but I remember meeting him
he's a nice guy yeah
what else man oh I heard you said you
guys were talking earlier about
um when I walked in you and the producer
Zach were talking about going to like a
kitchen or something oh yeah so
yesterday we were in La we had a free
day because like I said our shoot was
super late last night we shot like 9 10
o'clock right and you guys were shooting
Sunday conversations so for people that
don't know uh Glennie is the bat is the
side kick the background dancer for
Caleb pressley's Sunday conversation and
he works with uh Barstool uh bar stool
yes sir yeah so I just sit there and eat
the ice cream try to make the guest
awkward yeah you've done it yeah
but uh yeah I know seriously we just had
a free day and I was telling your
producer that um I just set up a few of
the chefs I know it here and they just
want to take me to lunch and that's like
one of my favorite things I just love
hanging out with chefs I find it so cool
as a guy that obviously enjoys food I
enjoy food more than just eating it like
I just I love the whole idea of culinary
[__] and food so they took me to the
Beverly Hills Cheese Shop one like the
back room like in Goodfellows put on
some like classic Italian music they
just brought us out a bunch of these
cheeses important from Italy imported
from Italy look wait hit the next one
look at the table look at the back room
that was the back room oh so there's a
back road it was it was a back room full
experience brought us out a few Bronies
plated cheese some sun-dried tomatoes
some stuffed cherry peppers all like
this low moisture mozzarella they just
made Buffalo mozzarella Straight From
Italy they said it lands in LAX every
Tuesday so we kind of got the shitty one
it was a Monday but it was still great
yeah we got we got the end of the week
Buffalo mozzarella but Buffalo what's
real it's kind of like that one thing
even when it's bad it's good it was fast
where they find it from Buffalo they
said no no they fly from Italy oh wow
because he was Buffalo milk in Italy
that's why it's like Buffalo mozzarella
oh and so it's oh it's out of the
buffalo animal yes sir oh like the milk
they use is from Buffalo milk so that's
like so if you're getting mozzarell from
Italy it's most of the time Buffalo
mozzarella not what she would Envision
just straight fresh mozzarellas here
yeah Oh I thought somebody was milking
Dawson Knox up there or something you
know don't be good looking piece of
cheese
it wouldn't be bad right uh so you take
so they now how does that even work so I
never you get hooked up with like a lot
of back room you so you go into the back
or like who comes out is it like the the
top like the cheese Monger among these
are Monger really yeah so that's what
happens so um and what is a monger let's
look it up that I believe it's cheese
Mark is that that's only from watching
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
Charlie's dad was a cheese Monger
because cheese Monger is somebody that
would die for cheese right I think this
man would die for cheese this guy Dom we
were both yesterday he would definitely
die for cheese he would take one on the
cheek for cheese
yeah a merchant who specializes in Jesus
okay
um and what's a monger just overall
because they have a war Monger I hear of
all the time yeah sounds something like
Mongolian Maybe
yeah it was just a monger I could see
that Genghis Khan being a monger uh like
a broker or a dealer of something okay
oh I want [__] yeah I guess why is the
cheese Monger I guess yeah
so okay so you get there the guy comes
out yeah so great chef Aaron may but as
we met iron maid there and then the guy
came out in Med Aaron and then Dom came
out mid iron then they just said let's
go in the back and then they literally
brought us in the back like we were in
Goodfellas set up plates forks knives
plates for us brought us out Peyronie's
brought in these cheese plates and I'm a
first anchovy they brought out
apparently this this fantastic fantastic
anchovy Straight From Italy as well was
it alive when they brought it out or not
it was I was in a can it was like a
little tiny aluminum can but I equated
it so my first time golf my first time
on a golf course was Pebble Beach and I
told I told them yesterday that's what
this was like because I'm having anchovy
and Porter from Italy first anchovy
instead of on a shitty pizza so the
anchovy was damn good put a little
anchovy on bread a little Buffalo
mozzarella so dried tomato on it and
then oh they had imported olive oil from
Italy it was it was it was
an Immaculate time that's some more
right it was Immaculate dude hey if
you're ever in a lane you want to go
we'll go yeah man I can't I see it up I
don't get offered things like that it
must be because obviously I guess people
assume that you have you uh enjoy food I
very much do and no no not in a
stereotypical fat guy way right like I
don't this may shock you I don't eat
like I don't eat too much fast food
right it's not like I'm going home and
pounding Burger King every day it's just
yeah I I appreciate good food yeah good
food is is
the best it is good man I think I I grew
up on just really not good food right so
I think there was no appreciation for
food exactly I'm the same way like I
never grew up like going insanely nice
steakhouses and whatnot but even I mean
there's also bad food that's fantastic
as well I was talking to a co-worker of
mine last week Kate she was saying she
grew up always eating the uh the very
very thin pork chops that once you cook
them like you could see like the white
bubbles yeah pop up on them those are
pretty damn good oh I don't mind them it
is interesting how they have that fat
bubbles that bubbles the fats bubbling
I'm taking it it's it's the cheap pork
chops but they do the job Mmm Yeah I'm
trying to think of something else that
we oh you know what was big when I was
young uh fish sticks really you ever do
fish sticks I never did I never did
maybe I don't know that was maybe
Louisiana thing there was more fish
sticks by you but I'm also I also grew
up by the water too but I never dabbled
in a fish stick what is it I guess
theoretically just a what about a warm
clam or something come across the table
Yeah well yeah yeah never never home I
don't know if I can one time I tried to
make clams in my house it was a massive
failure yeah you have to because you
literally have to wait to make sure if
they're alive or not if they don't um if
they don't open immediately they're
still alive so if you're the pride open
it's dead you can't eat it so that was
troubling to me and then I tried to talk
about the barbecue it didn't work out
and how do you know if they're alive as
you could do like you just like whisper
in there like how do you even know I
believe what the process was was you put
them in under hot water you boil you
boil them and then one of the ones that
crack open are dead and then that's the
ones you eat
during covert I tried to just expand my
culinary life yeah and it was during
covet so it was probably three years ago
now but the ones that don't open
dead big dead they're dead dead and you
can't Prime open and eat them because
that would be the dead thing oh yeah and
you know what I think there's something
like even in the clam culture you don't
you don't like after something's buried
you don't go get you know no you don't
get in the coffin with it absolutely not
and then we can't cook it we gotta eat
raw clams I wonder if I were to make a
bait clam though if I could have a dead
baked clam
I don't that's a good question see
that's the problem because then you
they're all closed right so you don't
know the difference well the bay climb
is usually they'll like take the clam
they'll shuck the clams take the clam
out oh yeah and then put it in but I'll
put on the half shell and then but like
bake it so it gets cooked I mean
everything is dead before it gets cooked
yeah but raw clam obviously can't even
Dead one I guess it always interests me
that clam is an oyster living things oh
someone told me one time that clams are
like oysters that got molested when they
were kids and never grew up yeah I could
I could kind of see it I mean I when I
do Envision clams and oysters I think of
oysters as maybe say the grandfather of
shellfish yeah they're definitely the
elders they're the senior citizens oh
they definitely they have like a
newspaper under there yeah oh yeah maybe
maybe a walker yeah yeah yeah trying to
just ring a little clams and talk tell
them about the old days yeah
and then the muscles too I love a good
muscle but those are the big three it's
hard to denote sometimes the difference
from me between clams and muscles let's
look at what is the what is the purpose
of oysters in the ocean Zach let's look
it up because we've had recently we've
actually been talking about this on here
that oysters are like a um I would bet
they're pretty vital honestly yeah
oysters are a crucial component of
global ocean Health these animals oh
they're animals filter and clean the
surrounding water and provide habitat
food and jobs wow
so they're kind of like a um like a temp
service or something maybe I guess and
their reefs can also serve as barriers
to storms and Tides
um that's pretty sick
wow so they they got a lot of
responsibility how did they filter can
you look up how oysters filter in the
ocean
because if they're filters and this is
the crazy part
that if they're filters always just
comes in other shellfish help remove
excess nitrogen from Waters by
incorporating it into their shells and
tissues as they grow that would make
sense if I've never seen a clean oyster
shell
they're all pretty damn dirty they're
all got a little bit of dirt in there
they're sacrificing themselves for the
ocean apparently which is interesting
which are the new every day but that's
crazy then so say you broke into like a
trap house right somewhere yes sir and
there's some dude in there he's dirtied
up right he's got soil he even have a
little bit of soil around his mouth
right and then you just put it right you
put horseradish on it you were dumping
horseradish on it well because that's
where like an oyster is yeah dude you're
right I know horseradish would take them
out pretty quickly so always try to show
kind of like it would be his Kryptonite
yeah I mean it's Kryptonite but then you
eat them like that's what you're doing
you're break you're basically because
the oyster is like something like it's a
like a like a car filter maybe your
grandfather's car filter he would turn
off the little screw thing he'd open
he'd pull that filter out yes sir so
that's kind of what we're eating dude I
would eat anything with horseradish
honestly I don't care horseradish is
damn good it is good horseradish fan a
little cocktail sauce on it as well oh
yeah yeah you're right who am I you know
what I'm saying what am I I don't want
to ruin that for anybody
um so you guys so so take me through
this first anchovy it's right there it's
by itself he brings out a canister of
him how many he's in there he brings out
a canister there was about six of us
there I would say we've got to try one
maybe two extra so I'm gonna go with
there was about eight in the canister
there was a little tiny oval thing like
this and like I said I was lucky enough
to be there with Christian petroni and
Aaron May two world class chefs so iron
said you gotta try your first oyster I
said pal you're making it for me so I
got this
wonderful Chef making it for me we have
this great bread that I think they said
this exclusive elderly lady down the
street baked for them every day had the
bread yeah that really does look gross
the envisioning of the of the anchovy
just by itself that really does not look
good and that's the Buffalo mozzarella
on the plate there as well but uh Little
Bread Buffalo mozzarella anchovy
sun-dried tomato he made it for me
squished it all down dollop of olive oil
on top it was it was a delightful bite a
little salty a little salty very salty
but still I'm very happy I tried it
those uh the anchov are very salty right
extremely from what I know I mean I'm an
anchovy virgin I just lost my virginity
24 hours ago damn but and they now why
is it I noticed when you say like
mozzarella and I've noticed when people
say salaam okay
um they don't when they go back to Italy
they take off one like we added a letter
yes so I think I think they did it and
we took the letter off from from my
knowledge I believe that the thing is
when the Italians like came over to
America their broken dialect cut off a
cut off a um The Vow at the end so let's
say I only really say what's wrong but
like mozzarella say mozzarella
um prosciutto they say proscute
um capicola they say gabagool no yeah
the gabagool goes a little overboard I
can't go to an Italian deli and with a
straight face but like let me get the
gabagool I can't do that with a straight
face but I can't say oh I'll have the
mozzarella but that's pretty much it yes
project
Regatta people say regard yeah
like parents say that like grandparents
in New York etc etc but I only really
say what's wrong in my normal day
um calamari they said Gala mod
no way yeah but I can't go into a deli
with a straight face and or let me get a
and be like let me get a hero with
Pursuit and gamble on it but mozzarella
I say or some vagina
sounds great throw it on there I'm not
going to say no to that one I mean I
just wonder like what other because yeah
that I guess it makes it sound fancier
because you're almost saying I'm gonna
be the last letter sure yeah it's like I
don't need to just put the letter on
there I'm gonna show you in my
ambiance or my
and at the end of the day there's a lot
more fun to say yeah they're a lot more
fun to say Rick ricotta that
what's more fun sitting there saying
ricotta or saying
exactly yeah it does but it's
interesting letters huh yeah a lot of
vowels we got a lot of vowels the
Italians yeah everything ends in a vowel
um mostly Jose's all my friend group I
think there's 11 of us probably
nine of us have vowel endings
and are your parents like fresh off the
uh no we're pretty Americanized Italian
I don't even know
I don't even know um like what um
generation of my family even came from
Italy honestly I but my we're pretty
pretty Americanized Italian about as
Americanized as Italian as it comes but
we're on the island still so everyone
it's literally only Italian or Irish
that's pretty much it is it yeah I like
that they're North Shore is very uh
there's a lot of Jewish Folks up there
and then the South Shore where I'm from
it's literally just like Italian and
Irish yeah
um do they have um so that's where you
so that's so that's where you grew up at
I I was born originally in Corona Queens
it's where my parents are from and then
we moved to
um Malvern Long Island when I was
probably I don't know four four or five
in that realm so I grew up on the line
I'd always say what you grow up is where
you went to high school I think that's a
fair assumption
I feel like that's your formative years
where you went to high school yeah we
went to high school was ready from now
in Italian culture if a woman is like
kind of do you describe women like also
as like um
relate them to like pastas or something
I was thinking maybe like this girl's a
real vermicelli this girl's real
farfalla yeah no but we could I mean
there's a lot of great pasta just popper
though there's uh rigatoni I've never
equated women to a pasta though
vermicelli is very like it's almost like
uh she's a little thin yeah you go
linguine there too as well it's like
even thinner linguine is pretty damn
thins it's like a very very thin
spaghetti like vermicelli has to be
thinner have vermicelli yo can you look
up vermicelli I don't know I want to
look at make sure I know exactly what
we're talking about dude I'm eating
vermicelli it's almost like I want to
make sure it's parents aren't home you
know it feels very uh
is definitely thinner than um linguine
yeah okay so there's vermicelli okay
we're just looking at images here can we
get it do they have a chart somewhere
look at that nest of vermicello let's
get a pasta chart up here yeah my
personal favorite is pappardelle I think
I'm a pappardelle guy see I'm not even
familiar with it
oh there we go
yeah I like the farfalli that's really
good there's a there's a good great
sausage dish by me that there's a
sausage for fale so I'm impartial that
but um I mean Penny's classic if I could
date one Queen though
maybe go with the fusilli oh yeah
you don't know what you're getting dude
and where is that one it's like right
there oh in the middle and the top it's
like spirally looking playing a mystery
game oh yeah that one definitely had you
could see it having some bipolar issues
let's go down a little bit I want to see
what else is on here oh that rigatone Dr
rigatoni that's that's I would say
that's the classic out so that's the
that's the that's like just blonde blue
eyes nothing better than that it's an
All-American classic the rigatone yeah
the rigatone and what if you get that
thick Asian girl what's that one that
pad thai or what's the one that has like
those uh egg noodles okay what are the
actual noodles on that yeah I think it
might be just egg noodles yeah because I
don't think I don't think they could I
mean they're kind of technically the
same I had Robin for the first time last
week I don't know what the really yeah I
just dove into it a new place open by my
house so I just said [__] it let's try
it and did you go alone I went with my
cousin and my dad okay so if it's going
to eat like at a new place is that a
family thing for you guys um no as
honestly we were at Easter and I was
having a few Beverages and I just told
my cup my little cousin that I want to
um go to the ramen place he said he said
I want to go too so I said you know what
[__] it I'll take the guy yeah I've had
a nice meal it was fine it was good for
Monday night I'll take a Monday night
meal I didn't have to cut up the Monday
nights I'll happily go to
to sit on my bed and watch YouTube all
night and that's the point of that it's
not fun you just sit there and wait for
enough time to pass to then go to sleep
so yeah Monday night's thing Monday
Tuesday Wednesdays yeah I guess there is
something about it maybe
um
that's like you're waiting for the fun
to happen well most people also work you
got to get some work those are kind of
work days yeah you know like we're on a
Tuesday right now 100 so it's like we're
able to get this done if the Friday
sometimes are tougher to fit things in
you feel like the week is like you've I
kind of feel like the weekend's just
about to get its period I feel like it's
just like everything is just about to
come crashing down now I'm just a fan of
the weekend Duty right I mean basically
Monday and Wednesday I just sit around
and do not I'm not I'm just sitting
around and doing nothing yeah
waiting for maybe even Thursday I'd like
to do a nice dinner me and my friends
have been doing dinner Thursdays which
is quite nice because now I'm old I'm
older I appreciate it like I said it's a
good meal good meal with Pals is fine to
me it's like I like Thursday kick off
the weekend kind of brings me back to
high school we used to go to Applebee's
every Thursday night a couple half apps
yeah Morgan and Morgan
they are America's largest injury Law
Firm
if you've been hurt at work or in a uh
you know something happened bam
something fell on your washer dryer
you know heck even if a UFO dang hits
you where they might be able to help
Morgan and Morgan
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for clients
they have a true proven track record of
fighting to get you full and fair
compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
Morgan is so easy it's more like you
using an app than hiring a lawyer
uh with Morgan Morgan you can submit a
claim without ever having to leave your
couch
that's right in eight clicks or less you
can submit a claim to Morgan and Morgan
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com slash this past
weekend
or dial pound law that's pound 529 from
your cell phone that's for the
people.com slash this past weekend or
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement using the internet without
expressvpn is like walking your dog in
public without securing them on a leash
don't do it
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but what if one day your dog runs away
or gets dog napped oh dang
it's better to be careful especially
when it's as simple as it's using
expressvpn get an extra three months of
expressvpn free at expressvpn.com
Theo that's
expressvpn.com Theo
expressvpn.com Theo look I'm gonna be
honest with you do you want to nerd the
[__] out homie
do you want to grab your shy girlfriend
and go nerd the [__] out well RTX is a
gaming comedy animation and podcast
Festival that's happening in Austin
Texas at the convention center from July
7th to the ninth that's right it's a Fan
Expo that Rooster Teeth a Digital
entertainment company out of Austin has
been throwing since
2011. there will be new shows that are
debuting they lighten new uh candles
over there with the return of the
animated show camp Camp
they got gameplay competitions on the
main stage Live Comedy uh everything
from mini golf to Paranormal themed
Escape rooms
they have an f-face Museum
that sounds interesting
um and they even have random ass things
like Jackie Chan's tuxedo from The
Tuxedo
their evening events from parties comedy
showcases and everything in between
that's in Austin exclusively just for
our fans you can get discounted rates
for regular badge prices go to
rtxaustin.com and enter code Theo don't
miss out on one of the biggest parties
in Austin this summer
dude it was something nice about trying
to make love to somebody that worked at
the Applebee's wasn't there that's I
never tried we never had any uh
we had a lot of waiters not waitresses
but I could totally see it Applebee's is
a cool spot it's a cool hookup spot for
the olds yeah I saw one time I saw a mom
I grew up with out there on a date one
night tried to try to join them and I'll
make eye contact with her I didn't make
eye contact with her thank God but like
I got Applebee's I'm sure they have nice
I'm sure they have nice deals frankly
yeah well I think Applebee's has kind of
been
um
you know in a lot of places Applebee's
is that first place you get to go you
know it's like the first for some places
the first restaurant you know like like
where I'm from like my niece I was
talking to her yesterday and she I was
she's like you know my favorite
restaurant is Jimmy John's and I was
like well that's
that's not really a restaurant but it is
a restaurant depending on where you're
at 100 I've learned that recently since
we started Sunday conversation in the
last few years I've been traveling so
much and I that's like one of the first
things I tell my friends when we're
talking about kind of just even the
middle of America or anywhere really
that's not a massive City
like if you're a kid in Indiana you're
deli's Jimmy John's yeah your pizza is
Papa John's which is
crazy for my brain to think about but
that's just how it is and I never
realized that yeah and I thought I mean
not the syndrome with Jimmy John's I
love Jimmy John's I'm a mess of fan of
Jimmy John's I don't know how they do it
so fast and the bread is so good with
the oil but yeah like any random person
growing up I guess their Deli
technically is Jimmy John's yeah yeah
it's interesting that's kind of how you
learn about even anything seeing things
like a mozzarella cheese or something
like a um like some people it's like you
know uh they'll have like a one of those
like um Italian restaurants and they put
a new like pasta and that's how you
learn about the pasta and I love seeing
I love seeing Italian restaurants where
ever been any random place around let's
say we're in Texas
nine out of ten names are literally just
Paisanos yeah those are just the names
of all of them it's crazy I don't even
know if there's ever been a bowl of
fresh mozzarella in Topeka Kansas has
there been I have no idea maybe you're
in prohibition or something oh yeah when
they were just when people were running
out of alcohol and they were trying to
suffice them with other stuff you know
they're worse things to be sufficed by
yeah God I guess it is pretty good I'm
trying to think if I know about a lot of
different cheeses or not I didn't until
yesterday
I don't I'm not I'm not a massive
massive cheese person though it doesn't
doesn't rev my engine really not really
you just went into a back room and with
a bunch of men you didn't know to get it
and well hey I was told to go there I
said these chefs are taking me to lunch
I'm letting them rock that oh I'm
letting them go that would I mean that
would be like
right that would be like going to play
basketball with Michael Jordan and me
picking the teams okay yeah so I just
said I'm going to you guys rocking hey
it was great cheat the cheese was great
I mean I I also counter said that as I
would say a bite of good fresh
mozzarella's up there for one of my
favorite bites I've had just in life in
general but outside of that she doesn't
doesn't absurdly do it for me yeah yeah
now a lot of people are wanting to know
and I'm still wanting to know so you had
six anchovies in the can have there was
it was eight anchovies there were six of
you guys what do you do with those last
two I don't know who took the other last
one but um one of their chefs uh did say
I should say the last one because it was
would only be my second and show you all
time so I had two of the anchovy so I
guess I wasn't anchovy Glutton but I
enjoyed them did you change the way you
ate it the second time
um no same way I said because once again
the chef iramay told me
have the sanchovy I said dude only if
you Chef it up for me again if he's
there I want them to be the chefs you
know oh yeah I want them to be the the
guides the more spiritual guides there's
something kind of a there's something I
don't want to see erotic but there is
something very sensual about getting a
good food because you're putting it on
your tongue yeah you know people don't
realize that a lot a lot of times people
are just like I'm putting something in
my mouth you know I'm having this I'm
getting it I'm inhaling I'm bringing it
into me but that tongue is right there
too the tongue is very sexual hey
there's a lot of aphrodisiacs out there
as well yeah oysters oysters is Big
aphrodisiac which is crazy because they
collect junk out of the ocean but it
said they bring in Nitro nitrogen is
nitrogen aphrodisiac
I'm not totally sure what the rest of
the aphrodisiacs are
I know Valentine's Day what else oh
Valentine's Day is a good one is
nitrogen aphrodisiac let me see
ooh traditional plant aphrodisiacs and
male sexual dysfunction
that sounds like the opposite it's
opposite day I've looked at it before
I'm sure chocolate definitely
figs oysters spicy chili peppers
strawberries
can you put why is oysters an
aphrodisiac
the bivalves what does it say is that uh
the bivalves do contain zinc which has
been found to be an essential nutrient
for testosterone production in
spermatogen spermatogenesis I assume
dude this could be really dumb as in
sync what we make coins out of
yeah
she could suck on a damn nickel boy and
get hard probably why not dude oh
especially if you're poor dude nothing
gets you hard in the good nickel imagine
a quarter oh imagine a silver dollar yes
imagine a silver dollar okay suck it on
that for a month oh my peeping time bro
I put a silver dollar on my tongue I'm a
Peeping George Washington Miller didn't
know it hit him
um so tell me how you grow up kind of in
this Italian environment and is it just
you is there other women in the
household is there other children I'm
actually an only child no way yeah yep
and why do your parents stop with just
you you think because I don't really we
were a handsome child huh uh no probably
not I was I was I was a a skinny child
until I always say I got Coxsackie and
then that kind of threw me off the rail
couldn't eat for a few weeks oh you got
a disease oh Kawasaki is like a few weak
disease but I couldn't eat for like two
months and I just said I had to make up
for lost time and I've just been making
up for lost time since you know because
that I do I do have like photos of me
when I was six seven years old and I was
I was a skinny little I was a skinny guy
really yeah and when you look at those
photos do you think because some people
look at weight as like
I mean how do you look at weight what am
I talking about how do I look I don't
really know I think it's more I mean I
want to say it's a mindset it's
obviously not a mindset but like I'm
pretty pretty happy with my with my
weight per se there was a time in my
life I was shockingly way bigger than I
was now like I think maybe like 50 60
pounds bigger and then I was like Wow
and I was like [__] dude
I'm a large gentleman I gotta travel I
should probably stop this
there's no reason to have a chicken
cutlet with bacon sandwich for lunch
every day there's no need for it not
every day so then I cut that off and
then look and then I cut that off and I
lost probably 20 pounds and then covet
hit and then I just stayed home and just
like drank every night at eight grilled
chicken every day and lost weight then
so now I'm like sitting at a steady like
290 295 right now you really weigh that
much yeah yeah you don't look that big
really yeah
I'm gonna play this clip whenever I walk
on an airplane because I always feel bad
walking on an airplane do you yeah dude
you have no idea how much airplane
stress I always have so take me through
that airplane stress so you're cause
yeah you know once you get to the
airport you know that you're big yeah I
know I know quite literally everybody on
this plane is looking at me saying
please don't sit here oh that's why it's
nice though because now I'm a Delta
Diamond guy no big deal I got to order I
got to
um
board the flight first yes so at least I
get that out of the way but I mean there
was one time Me Kate me Caleb and our
and our Girl Kelsey were traveling to um
Lake Tahoe from La so it was a quick
flight but our flight I canceled that
before so we had to go on a Southwest
flight last minute and we got like the
54th opening on Southwest how there's
this first come first serve so we were
three of the less people to sit down and
I was walking down the aisle and
literally I felt like Forrest Gump
getting on the bus knowing nobody wants
you to sit there were only middle seats
left then thank God Ro say 23 I saw like
a 12 year old kid by the window I said
you're my [__] just sat right
next to we took out well we hey we
became friends his name was Terry he was
a great kid he was like 13. we bonded
the whole flight he was saying he was
going to visit his grandparents in Reno
and we uh we had a great time we played
baseball on his iPad together he was
great but he say he saved my day because
I was quite literally [__] bricks
knowing every single person on this
plane is telling themselves please don't
sit here please don't sit here please
don't sit here it's a shitty feeling
that'll make you want to lose a little
weight it's like that Plinko game
but you don't want it to get in the you
don't want it to Lane the Southwest was
quite literally like it was a scary
experience because there were only
middle seats left there were only middle
seats left and then there was maybe
maybe the idea that there was an aisle
seat all the way in the back but should
I reach that instead of sitting next to
the 12 year old I went with the 12 year
old yeah you got to make that with a 12
year old and is it amazing that at that
point you go to the the warmth of
children you go to the kindness of a
young child who has yet to determine in
his head hey I don't like I don't want
to sit next to this fact to the fix yes
it was well it was it was not that Terry
was a great kid but it was also just uh
he's smaller he's a small guy okay so
he's a very small kid so small so you
guys put matching up together yeah there
it almost made sense it's a beautiful
relief whenever someone ever big skin
sits next to you it was like of mice and
meat yes that's a perfect example I mean
Terry we bonded we had a great time wow
yeah it was really nice but it's always
great like sometimes when you sit next
to a toddler again lucky for a toddler
sit next to you on a plane that's always
convenient wow at work we have we have a
shorter gentleman I like to sit next to
him if we travel together I've seen him
you guys did the uh yeah yeah we did our
first Morgan wallenson conversation he
took my place oh you might have seen him
in that yeah he put the brother and he
snuck in the brother on Walling yeah
well what happened was uh well what
happened was we uh we originally when we
first started sending conversation we
were doing two Rowan you know who ronas
[__] was also doing them as well so I
went I was I was pissed because at the
top I'm still a mess of fan but I always
loved Darius Rucker and that was the day
they were doing uh like a foreplay
scramble like with Wallen Hardy Darius
and Jake Owen and then we had me and
roan had a shoot with Doug Flutie in
Melbourne Florida and they said you're
gonna you're going to Doug Flutie zozgo
in a uh Troubadour to do the um shoot
with Wallen and I said [__] zaz about
to hang out all day with Darius man and
I'm sitting here with Doug Flutie in a
conference room with a Marriott in
Melbourne Beach Florida that sucked I
was disappointed about that luckily two
years later we did Darius on Sunday
conversation and that was great but
right that's the time it's stung it's
done yeah when the boss says the boss
says yeah
um so you're growing up their only child
right and what kind of work are you in
when you're doing are you a funny guy
what kind of kid are you and you're a
thicker kid you said you went through
the disease you got out of it you got
you got to start you and you started
thickening up yeah we thicked up we
picked up pretty good did the whole
family because sometimes there's kind of
like a thing where a whole family will
put on weight at the same time like
something happens a grandmother dies or
there's a
like a not a power outage but like a um
you know like a nuclear disaster or
something you know no I would say I
would say not to say so but we're
definitely a larger family I would say
half half thicks half non thicks okay
but in in like the Nafi media family
like my aunts and uncles well not but uh
growing up yeah I would just say it say
uh I would say a fun guy I don't think I
don't think absurdly funny but funnel
always hung out with the with the with
the good guys I'm still best friends
with all my friends growing up so yeah I
think I think relatively normal
childhood Catholic High School I'm
Catholic High School and grade school
that was interesting oh wow because
that's all boys in there huh uh no we
had co-ed our rival College uh high
school was
um all dudes but we were coming they
must have been so jealousy you guys yeah
dude the thing too with them is there
was so there were three high schools in
the area Catholic high schools Sacred
Heart was all girls Chaminade was all
boys and then Kellenberg where I went
was co-ed so they all had Sacred Heart I
think had Cotillion and Chaminade had
aquaprom so then we always had to watch
our few Sacred Heart friends trying to
match up so they all had to get each
other from a distance and we actually
had no problem at Kellenberg yeah our
prom got canceled for um flaunting of
affluence and what people being wealthy
yeah definitely not me but like other
people like got canceled in 2006 are
prompted so I never had a problem damn
yeah that was that was a whole big thing
Colbert talked about it on Colbert
Report he prom got canceled what
happened your problem got canceled yeah
well you'll do a fake prom somewhere so
our [__] prom our I guess our kind of
prom we did a boat ride around Manhattan
which pretty fun it was fun but hey let
me tell you as as a larger gentleman
that did not have sex in high school it
took a lot of stress away from having to
find a prom date oh wow what a relief
huh it was like sitting next to a
toddler on a plane seriously it was
quite nice that that I will say was fun
and then yeah I never had the problem
didn't have a problem
dude what if you don't think about that
you don't think about the other half of
the school because for the school that's
like yeah prom this is it I have a
girlfriend I have a boyfriend I'm lucky
um you know unisex I don't need anybody
he's American Pie myself yeah like but
then there's like half the people that
are like [__] I don't have anybody I'm
afraid to ask someone my partner is ill
or something
um I've been you know just all kind of
stuff yeah always two starts the story
it was so I enjoyed it I didn't mind it
Fox you're like wow yeah I said to
myself this is kind of nice I I was a
little concerned though people were
gonna start taking dates to this boat
ride luckily they didn't right and it
was fine we basically just hung out it
was dude do you remember how
nerve-wracking it was if somebody I
didn't have used to make to get a date
right
like we had like Sadie Hawkin right
where the kid had uh the girl had to buy
you a shirt right it was a matching
shirt okay
so first off my mom was like don't pick
out some girl that picks out shitty
shirts like right you know Grandma
already gets you shitty shirts every
year you need a good shirt
so now I have this pressure right and
I'm not you don't even get to pick the
girl picks you kind of like penguins
is it women's picks it I could be dumb
but I think women no sorry men present
the one with a pearl my apologies but
yes with a pearl yeah I believe that's
how they find it they find like a pearl
or something that's how they propose to
their ladies really yup I think so well
bring that up
I'm pretty sure I believe it's a pearl
that if he finds something I was
watching an animal show one time and
they like went to the end of the Earth
to find their thing to present their
lady I think you're watching maybe Ice
Age or something
I think it's something like that using a
pearl to propose I think so because I'm
not seeing anything on maybe not a pearl
but definitely something like they have
to find something and then give it to
the lady I'm pretty sure how do penguins
propose to one another
oh with pebbles Pebbles sorry
a less fancy Pearl it's a very good
point that's all a pebble is dude yeah a
pebble is just a pearl it finds the
smoothest pebble
isn't that nice romance people think
romance is Dena that's a good point
isn't it during courtship a male penguin
will find the smoothest Pebble to give
to a female as a gift if she likes the
offering she'll place it in the nest and
the two will continue building up their
little Pebble mound in preparation for
the eggs that's actually beautiful I
didn't know that that yeah I've been
crying right now I didn't know that that
was their beginning of the foundation
for their nest for their eggs that's
[__] cute dude that is so romantic
it's romantic it's first of all to even
be a penguin right and balance a little
Pebble yeah and they don't it's like
they look down at people's there they
gotta go find the smoothest Pebble yeah
and first of all how do you even lift
the pebble further because you can
barely even look down I don't think a
penguin so you have to almost get the
pebble way up here look at it maybe kick
it yes but then how do you test if it's
the smoothest oh
how about that
penguins are wild look at the one of
them giving it to the other one with the
Beak he gives it I think it's like When
Harry Met Sally
yeah
man that's some that's amazing
is there something else really romantic
that happens in nature see if you can
find some some of Nature's best romance
because the only other thing I've seen
is that lizard that guy who's like a
total perv that like
puts like the big fake yeah that's the
only other thing I was going to say as
well there was I'm pretty sure in one of
those shows I was watching one time I
think it was some sort of a burn he
literally put on a like so you think
you'd dance s performance like he
literally
it was unbelievable he looked like
it looked like Chris Brown he was crazy
it did
and then I think he actually
so it really had a but he really popped
off on the day it's a lot of zebras it
was beautiful
flamingos dance for their love take us
through that Zach yeah there's a this
article is a couple examples but
flamingo's dance for their love I guess
in separate groups
um they struck together in search of a
mate seahorses I guess flirt a lot horny
um yeah
wolves
wolves made for life
now that's interesting wolves mate for
life yeah their packs are generally like
nuclear families that comprise an adult
male oh damn dude did you possibly see
that um that story out of Vegas about a
month or two ago that some sort of dog I
forget I think it was not it wasn't a
bulldog I think it was maybe a pit bull
was adopted by a pack of wolves outside
of Vegas and became their leader really
yeah damn Animal Control found him and
took him back but he became their leader
he was the leader of the pack wow they
didn't kill him and then let him become
the leader
huh yeah white dogs
rescued apparently he became the leader
of the crew wow
how they've got to make them see but
they won't make this movie you know
because it's probably too much violence
I could animate it you know like they
won't make like babe a pig in the Crips
you know that's fair I would love to see
this though yeah I made animated for
adults
maybe make like Charlie Hunnam the lead
voice in an American accent and his Jax
Teller accent
yeah oh that would be nice how with
Miles Teller in it oh I'm down for Miles
Teller as well dude we should make a new
outsiders with Miles Teller in it
remember The Outsiders that of course
was that Tom Tom Cruise in The Outsiders
or am I thinking of Stand By Me I'm
mixing them up no Tom Cruise wasn't in
Stand By Me I think he might have been
in The Outsiders was he as Outsiders say
golden Ponyboy yeah yes I think he came
like Rob Lowe yes Rob Lowe Tom Cruise
my Tom Cruise was in there Matt Dillon
machio Patrick Swayze that's a goddamn
power crew it's unreal it's like the 80s
Avengers yeah see Thomas Howe that's
unbelievable
um
what were we talking about uh your lady
in high school even finding you a good
shirt yeah thank you man wow you're a
good you know what you're doing
um so yeah the girl had to pick out the
shirt you know and I never really had I
didn't have like the girlfriend I always
had kind of like the one where you kind
of got set up I wasn't in the circle of
like getting the notes from the girls a
lot and stuff so it was always like you
like I was always a little bit on the
outside of like my friend Scott would
always get the date and then one of her
friends and I would go with one of the
friends and um
yeah and then you would just hope that
Scott made out with some girl so he
could tell you about it did you do prom
though
um yep I went to prom oh dude how did
you go about doing your date
well so prom
um I there was a girl that came into the
office because I used to go in the
office and hang out in there right and
flirt with this lady that kind of looked
like an animal a little bit but she
worked at our school
so why go in there bro and kind of flirt
with her and stuff and just kind of
because I wanted to be out of class so
I'd go in there and just sit in there
and you know and uh and then they gave
me a job and they're working behind the
desk I didn't do anything but at least I
was in there for a reason now so they
could like so it wasn't like an
insurance issue or whatever
so one day this girl came in
and she needed something from me so she
like asked so it was like
I always had the toughest time kind of
talking to the girls to want this girl
kind of needed something from me it was
like suddenly I was like of use you know
so I started flirting a little bit and
then next thing you know we uh
we ended up dating and
um made love
and um
I took her to the school day we went to
the school prom but
what happened she uh left to go to an
after party early no yes and I got stuck
so I had to draw I drove this one this
one uh white guy that went to our school
he uh wore like one of he wore like a um
a Blazer that had those shoulder pads in
it nice like single bombs you just have
to wear because the husband had left you
know sure and
um so he wore that and I remember I was
like dude I'll give you a ride
and he's like all right cool and so
we're driving to the party and he breaks
down crying bro so now I want to get to
this party because you know in high
school you only kind of get so many
chances to make love to your girl right
but what was the love made already
before this party or this was your it
was made before okay but this was still
like prom night it's still still a Super
Bowl of the love it's the Super Bowl of
high school love making Hobbies yes yeah
that's it yeah it's the biggest deal
from what I see in the movies because I
don't have one yeah yeah so you're
excited bro and he starts telling me
this dude had the craziest he kept
saying that people thought he looked
like
something people thought he looked like
Damon Wayans right and he was a white
guy
and right then I knew he's nobody
thought that right and he's just kind of
like losing his [__] bring up a picture
of Damon Wayans if you can
the daddy
and he's like man people expect so much
out of me you know uh I was like dude
nobody you know I'm just thinking nobody
and he's a white guy I mean this guy's
black Damon Wayans is black
so anyway I knew him like [__] dude but
the guy's crying so it's like it's you
it's so hard to get from somebody crying
to okay de-escalate the situation and
get over to you know before your day
gets too drunk where you can't make out
yeah that's yeah so did you uh or were
you feel comfortable making out also of
course you were gonna say did you so did
you want him not going to party
no we got there man but I had to sit for
like a half hour and be in the car with
him while he cried and then um some mood
kill buzz kill oh it was the worst
because I kept just one like it's going
to open the door every every five
minutes yeah that that's that's tough
and he's like man and people expect so
much out of me man people expect so much
out of me and I'm like nobody even knows
what you're talking about hey look at
those two guys with bad prom experiences
yeah what was yours you didn't have one
at all it got canceled now we got none
at all it's yours guys we literally just
had that belt ride so was it weird going
into summer then not have having made
love yet
um it was a little odd because that was
uh it was summer and then we were going
to college
and college was interesting Yeah Carl
now College showing up to college I
think having made love or not made love
that seems like a
I wonder what that feels like to a guy I
mean I know what it feels like but I'd
made love yeah yeah so like you kind of
had that monkey off your nuts or
whatever you know yeah College was a
scary ass time I really did not like it
I went to UAlbany for like three
semesters you Albany was it was an odd
it's an odd place there's I'm on record
saying I think the most
satanic people or in Upstate New York
yeah there's just a Eerie vibe in
Upstate New York it's an eerie Eerie
Place yeah a lot of neck tattoos a lot
of [__] people getting punched in the
back of the head while they're trying to
get a TV dinner that kind of [__] that's
very fair yeah it's it's a creepy creepy
odd place I mean there was there was one
time where literally I was
um
it was on my freshman year first
semester
I would stay on the eighth floor we were
lucky enough I like won the lottery of
being in the nice tower being in the
good Tower that's a brand new tower
Indian Tower was called which was
awesome like were you big were you
physically larger at this point or not
um oh yeah I would say a little larger
than I am now okay but um not not as big
as I had gone like I said but um so we
were in there it was eighth four always
remember it was great we had communal
bathrooms not a community about them
sweet so we only switched over like six
people great times for some reason
though whenever for that first semester
we were drinking like
personal is a Bacardi every Friday night
I don't know why we were drinking
personals of what is that gin I think
gin it's kind of homeless sexy kind of
yeah we're sticking like Bacardi Apple
personals no idea why but either way it
was Friday it was Friday night one night
and I'm a noted [__] like about many
things like definitely Supernatural
stuff like about what drinking and [__]
like that no no no actually you know fun
fact I was the last of my friends to
start drinking I started drinking in the
junior year at this oh okay yeah this
weird thing called The Coliseum but
that's another in college or in high
school uh High School I used to walk
around and tell my friends I'm gonna be
the DD I can't wait till I get my
license I'll drive everybody around oh
yeah we probably wanted to be a cab
driver I mean a lot of this is being
Italian yeah that one out at the door
though once I got that nice taste but oh
yeah after that um so okay so you're in
college you they got you rapunzled up
they got you Sugar Ray ponzled up in the
top of the tower you're living large you
got your own pisser up there
so it's Friday night we all have our
personals and then I we we elect me to
be the guy that night to go downstairs
to the basement get the sodas to chase
everything so I go down to the basement
get the sodas go back up to the A4 but
we'll stop at the first floor yeah
I step into the elevator and I oh I will
remember this clear as day step into the
elevator go to the back right corner of
it in walks in this kid that I've seen
on campus even though he was and this
girl that I saw on campus that I
definitely always found she just looked
a little creepy looked a little off oh
yeah
and I'm looking about and she's kind of
wizardy looking yes almost like like a
Harry Potter student yeah yeah and she
so I was in the back left corner this
kid stands directly in front of me in
the other Corner she immediately walks
in and sits down in the right corner to
me and I see her sitting down I tell
myself why the why is this girl sitting
down in the corner
elevator door closes as soon as the door
closed she starts like
freaking out almost like shaking and
screaming at the top of her lungs and
I'm trying not to look I look over to
her and she is covered in like satanic
writing there was like a 666 on her
forehead like a pentagram all over her
arm and I like I said I'm a massive
massive [__] I immediately I had it was
one of the probably the most scared I've
been in my life because I don't I don't
[__] with the satanic stuff in the
slightest yo who likes and she's no I
like there's people but and I'm sitting
there having
I was white as a ghost and then thank
God these girls who don't know got off
at four six they were getting on so I
jumped off of floor six those girls
immediately said this man is the most
unattractive man I've ever seen in my
life jumping out of that seeing me just
white as a [__] ghost but you know
what I went back up and my roommate
still says to this day that he's never
seen a human being truly white as a
ghost it was I was so terrified I didn't
know if there was some sort of like
satanic cult going on in the school or
if it was a joke I truly don't know to
this day so if you happen to be watching
this whatever your name was I would I
would love to know I don't know to this
day it was it was
terrifyingly scary this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp
we're grateful for them
and I'm grateful over the years to uh I
feel like beginning to know myself
you know it's interesting as you kind of
evolve you get to know yourself some
you're like oh
you know once you get used to everything
else in the world you're just like oh
dang I'm gonna learn about me
and if you have trouble getting to know
yourself
um better help
is there
they'll help you their therapy is about
deepening your self-awareness and
understanding
better help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
for no additional charge discover your
potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com Theo today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo you know I'm a
big fan of uh Raising Canes baby you
know it
my God boy
and if I see if I see Raising Canes I
want it
you know me all day dude I will I'll
crawl under something to get a dang a
Raising Cane
I want it
I want them chicken fingers daddy God
hmm I won't go put them fingers in me
that's how I just want it they got the
crinkle cut fries at Texas toast oh God
look at it
I love Raising Canes that's who I am and
uh and you can too you know and if you
want it and you desire it like I do I
like the Caniac combo
then uh then you can go onto their
website you can order online right now
raising canes.com they also have that
mobile app
that's right they're mobile
satisfy your Cane's fix fast by ordering
through their app
or online at raising canes.com or stop
by your local restaurant gosh
yeah you know they had a lot that you
know until Harry Potter came out that
the Wizarding group of people were like
a lot of the like Satanist kids that
Satan is Vibe yeah they've morphed some
of them I think when Harry Potter came
out they got they're like okay this is a
way for me to get out of this this is
our new thing right well this is a
chance if I'm not going full Satan and
I'm just Hufflepuff and round this is a
chance for me to
this is a way out which is not a lot of
agreed a lot of those people got onto
that now some people stayed Satan yeah
if you stayed on the second round you're
going straight to hell yeah I mean or
yeah or you're like a yeah if you're
like a Colts fan or what you know
whatever I don't know but some people
just stayed going out there but some
people got off on the Harry Potter when
that halt when Hogwarts rolled up
they're like I'm [__] thank God yeah
there were some guys that are Voldemort
guys they stayed in Voldemort guys yeah
they kept uh doing that you know it's a
little fun fact though apparently
satanists aren't actually I don't
believe in Satan they just believe in
nothing hmm which is odd but they also
but they also I think they worship like
the idol of like Baphomet which is that
dude with the goat head
Erb owls above let's bring up bials
above please oh yeah
uh you know what I'm curious about the
different satans yeah there's bezelbub I
think he was like I think bezel Bob was
actually like the the biblical Saiyan I
believe
yeah
that guy's creepy as hell I pick I think
of this I think of like I think of like
the villain in Tenacious D I wonder what
that guy would do huh that dude looking
like a corned up cougar with his little
Antichrist baby
that's tough stuff the scariest part is
that he has that baby because party is
going to want to help the baby
but part of you knows that that baby is
probably already compromised and that is
also the Antichrist that is the the
continuation of Satan I guess
theoretically like Rosemary's Baby you
ever see that movie that's Rosemary's
Baby right there baby hmm
I mean and that'll make you be Pro uh
Choice yes right
let's look at um look at different
satans can you look that up please I
just want to see some of the different
ones I've never thought about this the
different types of Satan they have now
there's that yeah
that's your Tenacious D Satan that's
your pop culture saying yeah that's your
very run-of-the-mill kind of everyday
Satan yeah
that's your everyday Satan that you're
like yeah three in the afternoon we need
a Satan ooh that look at Lucifer there
that's just a normal dude naked with
some wings
top left oh wow look at that so that guy
could really be anybody so that got
that's I feel like that was saying in
his human form before he went downstairs
that guy's got a top hat though I enjoy
that one
oh that's good like he's a businessman
like look here Monopoly went wrong yeah
like I'm gonna manage Elvis
wow you see a lot of that goat with
wings with horns it's the goat head
that's the one that'll get you the
pentagram
when was the first Satan
I think it just said that Lucifer's what
350 BC if you click on the men the naked
men
three or three years with the John
Milton's Paradise Lost ah okay
let's look that up Zach if you don't
mind when was the first Satan
what what is that in the Bible this is
bad for me I went through [__]
Catholic High School like I said
no look man this is oh look at that guy
okay Satan also known as the devil
and sometimes also called loose from
Christianity is an entity in the
abrahamic religions that seduces humans
into sin or falsehood hmm
ins in Judaism Satan has seen as an
agent figures that's the most you know
you gotta have an agent subservient to
God
typically regarded as a metaphor for the
yet yet or evil inclination so in the
evil inclination of God
what does that say is that
a figure known as Satan first appears in
the Hebrew Bible as a Heavenly
prosecutor that's what we're talking
about so he was good and that went bad
but it's first appeared in a Hebrew
Bible so that kind of means he was like
the Judge Judy kind of of
the Hebrews Bible right and then again
he went wrong he wanted all the power
for himself I guess that's normal yeah
it happens
um
all right so you're in college you got
things are going pretty cool you're
enjoying it I didn't love it I really
did not I just I love my friends from
home just a lot and I just kind of just
missed them you did yeah a lot a lot a
lot a lot then I transferred home I went
to uh I went to school at Baruch with
this like um business college on
Manhattan on 23rd and Lexington and then
I got hired at my job
beginning of the second semester of that
and more stool yes sir and then I did
two more finished that smash I did one
more and then I dropped out oh you
dropped out of college I am a College
Dropout yeah good times hmm whatever
yeah it was like six years ago now so
yeah I mean I think a lot of times
college is just if you don't even know
what to do people go into college yeah
it was scary because like my mom
obviously didn't want me to drop out but
then I kept telling her the point of
college is to get your dream job and I
have my dream job so why should I not
just drop out yeah for it and I would
venture to guess the experience I've had
in the six years since is well worth
more than a college degree in nothing I
had no major I was my shock yeah was
horrible math so when I transferred I
even when I transferred I had to do a
whole um
and what they call it intermediate or
remedial math class oh for a whole
semester I didn't even get credit for
the class and then to even get a major I
had to do like two more math courses
yeah so math really got me
yeah and when I yeah when I when I
dropped out I didn't even have a major
and I was a junior
yeah oh math will trip up any real you
know what I'm saying bro sorry sorry
but yeah
math will get you boy yeah but that that
was that was such a relief today I got
hired too because it was just so like
yeah well that was I mean Barcelona was
a huge corporation then I mean how long
have you been working there six years
dude I've been this September is going
to be seven wow but I I mean I got hired
Caleb hired me which is fun which is fun
to talk about now like quite literally
the day I got hired at work my mom
uh I was doing Tuesday Thursday Monday
Wednesday class then Friday there was
like a 20 minute recap of
the Monday Wednesday class so for the
first few weeks of that my mom was at
Baruch yep my mom was driving me into is
it a Jewish school or is this the name
of it Bernard Baruch is like a famous
business guy he may have been in the
tribe I'm sure he I think he was
actually is your family Jewish or no no
Italian okay Italian and Greek do they
have Italian Jewish people yeah I would
say I feel like Italians and Jews cross
mingle a lot so there's definitely some
yeah but um so my mom literally drove me
to the city that day because we were
doing a nice uh very wholesome we would
she would drop me off every Friday I
would go to my 20 minute recap and then
we'll go to a nice lunch in the city you
and your mother yeah it was nice yeah so
she saw how nervous I was I got the I
got the uh internship interview at 12 30
that day the class was from ended up
let's say 11 45 so she drove me over
there
and I was freaking out too because at
the time I was actually emailing with
what I thought was Erica nardini our CEO
it was really just her office manager
but they made it seem like it was a it
was who's office manager average office
manager his name was Brett he used to
work with us at Barstool yes sir so you
thought you were emailing with all with
the office manager from Barstool I
thought I was emailing with Erica as the
CEO but it was really Brett behind that
so I was I think I'm emailing Erica I
think it's like a business interview
type of thing as I'm going over there I
look at the Barstool Snapchat and I see
Caleb interviewing people so I'm saying
oh [__] this is kind of like a Content
thing and I'm [__] bricks because
now you're gonna be on camera I'm gonna
be on camera I was a fan of Caleb a fan
of everybody it was big Barstow fam and
you're and you're nervous your mother
knows your nervous terrifyingly nervous
and also one thing that's value now this
is a value of having children that I
think are thicker you know is that you
can see when they're nervous easier
that's fair I get rosy cheeks I get big
time Rosy Cheeks I've been told that a
lot and I think that there's something
about that as a mother it must be
because you have all these other mothers
the kids on pills for nine months dude
they have no idea but he weighs a
hundred and 21 pounds yes sir so she
knew I was worried and then um
I know it's a concert to be there I
didn't realize did you ever go to our
old office by any chance I did one time
so do you remember how you get off the
elevator and everyone's sitting right
there
uh yeah it's kind of alarming quite
terrifying so I'm a Barstool fan no idea
what I'm walking into I get off the
elevator everybody's sitting right there
extremely scary I go walk by the bar
they say stand there for a second go
talk to Caleb I'm shooting bricks I'm a
Caleb Presley fan at the time still am
and um he asked me he just sits me down
and asks me are you fast and I said you
know what for my size I am pretty fast
when I play softball I get down the line
pretty quick people will be shocked I've
beaten out of ground ball or two in my
day he says prove it let's go downstairs
to the street to a 28th and when my mom
dropped me off I said Claudia
driveway don't stay here I don't know
what's gonna happen just don't know his
name Claudia yeah I call her by Nick I
call her Claudia sometimes it's a
beautiful name yeah I like Claudia I
love saying so I like it so I call her
Claude sometimes she's clawed in my
phone but um shall we go outside she
didn't move so I'm [__] freaking out
my mom is literally right there and I'm
out there with the camera and Caleb I
was telling myself right she's right
there if you watch the video
and what is she's just hitting she's not
there probably sitting in the car
smoking a cigarette but she's he was
there that checks out and I think that's
awesome it was great yeah that was just
terrified if she was gonna get out of
the car and say something or anything
yeah we walked to the corner run down
the street Caleb says you know what you
are fish you're hired we go up talk to
Dave
as I'm walking out guys our our head of
social says what's your uh you have your
nicknames and I recently had watched um
Entourage and Goodfellas and Goodfellas
was a character named Sally balls
entourage is a character named Wally
balls I think just in my head I thought
Glennie balls would be a name but I I me
and my friends really jokingly name name
me that like I would call myself that
jokingly we were talking about gambling
or something
yeah like we want to talk about horse
racing or anything yeah and um Sammy
Spears Ronnie rounds yes sir you know
what I'm talking about so I said uh oh
my friends call me Glennie balls then I
think that I think the name is it's a
it's a catchy name I think it's a good
name and then um yeah then pretty crazy
we me and Caleb started hanging out and
what about Mom at that moment to get
hooked because the craziest thing that
moms do is not leave and then Pretenders
didn't pretend they left dude you know
what happened actually so it was right
it was right when Barstool first moved
to New York from like so everybody
living across the country finally moved
together every Friday they were doing
Aloha Fridays
so um everyone would dress on Hawaiian
shirts and make margaritas and [__] I
was only I had just turned 20. it's nice
like Christmas almost yes sir I had just
turned 20. and they immediately say
you're the intern go get us alcohol and
of course had fake IDs oh yeah but I
don't want to use a fake idea and maybe
get in trouble he just started as a Long
Island person using fake IDs in the city
was always a bit of a scary thing
so I called my mom like hey how far away
are you you're on the bridge yet
she comes back bought me all the alcohol
and then bought underage children
alcohol no my co-workers that were of
age oh because I was just scared to buy
it for I was scared to get like in
trouble using a fake ID so my mom came
back drove back to the office went to
the liquor store down the street bought
us the alcohol and then I just gave it
to everybody else I was scared to not
deliver yeah and then I got Caleb
Chipotle and that was my first day work
went to a Met game that night Caleb was
an interesting guy he's the most
interesting man that I've come across
he's very you know I think there's other
levels so there's layers to him that
more will be revealed I think yes I
think there's things about him that a
lot of us don't know
um
and I think we're gonna be learning I
hope so I mean I'm clearly a massive fan
as are you yeah great guy but yeah you
just wonder is there sometimes is there
a little ulterior motive somewhere in
that man you know he likes the uh he
likes to rabble rows you know he likes
the [__] smoke boy yeah he does he's
I mean he's a fun guy I love him I love
being with him I love hanging out with
him I'm still kind of scared of him but
I love him
um yeah he's an alarming guy
um great guy very interesting
um
yeah I went he came to a show in Florida
not long ago I had a show in uh Florida
and he came out
him
um
and he's he was he was pretty lit We
Were Gay and we went to the casino and
he's gambling he's uh I've gamble I
gambled with him in Lake Tahoe last year
out of that golf tournament out there
yeah he's a one Kayla it's not me and
him are different stages of Life he's
he's I think he just turned 30. he
doesn't jerk as much hang out as much
but like I like to I like to go out
whenever we're traveling it's just I'm
like I'm traveling I mind if I'm in a
Tuesday in L.A why not go out why don't
you go out yeah all I get messages all
the time you and I are not we're not
super close you know we kind of got you
know we've met each other a few times
but yeah and I'm glad we're getting to
spend time today and
um but I'll get messages like Glenny
balls is in town yeah I like to go out I
like I like to I like to enjoy I like to
enjoy the city is that I travel that I'm
lucky enough to travel to for work so
but I would say maybe once every few
trips I'll get Caleb out with me and
when as you know when he's out and
having fun he's just the most fun
funniest person to to enjoy in that
whole time we're in like Tahoe he just
he was just having a great time and he
was he's just so much I love him he's
just so much fun yeah he's a Creator man
I was kind a joke and he's a Creator he
like well I mean he got all he got he
was pretty fire he was pretty lit right
so he's pretty lit and he starts
bragging everybody that he went to Wells
Fargo earlier right he starts saying it
like it's a like he went to like some
fancy place like Sees Candy or something
you know he's like yeah he makes a new
bit every time he gets drunk pretty much
yeah he's like yeah Wells Fargo this
afternoon he keeps you know he's like oh
I got some size tens from Wells Fargo
I'm picturing him saying it exactly so
he got I guess two thousand dollars out
of his bank account at this point he's
up twenty thousand dollars right yeah I
haven't bet a bit
um Dustin poirier's air Mitchell
trubisky Cole Holcomb some of his uh
Kayla yeah
some of my close friends uh sitting
there doing a little bit of gambling and
Caleb was like he just wants to bet it
all he wants to lose it all he's trying
to buy a car for the lady that's working
there he wants he there he wants them to
send a [__] uh Kia dealer to the
table like you're it's at a certain
point that's like what is going it's
just it's unbelievable and if you tell
him to cash out he will not no he's the
best he's the best I mean we were I like
Tahoe too we were there like at that
tournament in the High Roller room for I
think four nights in a row because
that's all where everybody was hanging
out and there was one night we lost them
I lost him till 3am I couldn't find him
I had to know where his phone was I
finally found the median chili with
Kevin from the office at the bar two
blocks away I literally was looking for
him for two hours and I found it with
Kevin from the office eating chili which
is like once again it's like playing
basketball with Michael Jordan Schilling
with Kevin from the office buddy yeah
he's just he's he's a raucous time when
you go when you get him going yeah you'd
never he he is like an ingredient where
it's like okay they're like you can put
this ingredient in the recipe and like
what did you like what is the ingredient
they're like we don't know what the
ingredient is and I I know whenever I
get it I'm so excited to savor it yeah
like even one of the few times I've been
in the same city as soon as like he just
I was living in Nashville and he and I
go to Nashville a lot so I would like
whenever I go I'd feel weird not texting
him I'll throw him a text usually it
just doesn't answer which is fine yeah
that's who he is but um
like this weekend too he's back in
Florida and I'm going to Del Rey this
weekend I told him before when we got
another shoe last night I was like hey
I'll be in Delray this weekend I'm going
to grab lunch or anything probably won't
see him but it's all right I don't mind
I'm with my friends anyway right you
touch base yeah I just want to make sure
hey if you want to hang out I'll hang
out but like I'm not confident we'll get
him out for a night this weekend but if
we did I would be thrilled he's just one
of those he's one of those guys you see
him at a party he just got he gravity to
him yeah there's something that's uh
wonderful about there is something
that's very wonderful about him
um and people like him of course and so
many people like him that it also makes
you be like oh there is something
definitely uh
I don't know if that it's not that you
do it because everybody else said but
everybody likes him you know some people
just have that quality yeah that
everybody just likes yeah you're just
radiant yeah he gets a great quality man
he gots a great quality I think one of
my favorite okay actually this is a kind
of stupid that's not even not funny but
one of my favorite things that we've
done is he kind of has like a Sunday
conversation uniform the white shirt bow
tie hair down that same day we run that
Southwest flight we just finished a
shoot with Amelia de moldenborg and then
we just went to the bar and drank all
day and then flew to Reno to go to Tahoe
and just seeing the few stunning
conversation fans at the airport on the
plane seeing him in his son he didn't
take it off he didn't change it was like
seeing Clark Kent trash to Superman I
just seeing Caleb caught a drug roaming
down the aisle it is something
conversation full outfit it was so funny
you're seeing the Beatles reactions
is there just some days he just did it
give a [__] it that was one of the days
it was great it is kind of weird like
being like a talking head in a way like
which all of us kind of are a lot of us
kind of are on uh social media because
that's kind of what you see and then
people see you in real life and they
people always comment on I thought you
were smaller I thought you were taller I
thought you you know we're in a
wheelchair like people always have like
different
you know they they never get to it's the
first time they've ever seen you you
know or they're like what do you do when
you interviewing someone here and you're
like I'm at Aunt Anne's yes I'm having a
I'm not you know there's nobody you know
I'm just relaxed my main ones I just get
it's always worse Caleb yeah I got a lot
of words Caleb yeah which I I now I just
say he's like he's over there he's gonna
drink the other bar he'll just stays
here and uh and then my other show I do
I interview only fans models so I pretty
much 99 of the questions I get now and
I'm out of bars between me and you yeah
you [__] those chicks right Presley
or puss I like president
well and uh yeah we don't even say it we
don't even say uh
hear how I pointed to you you said all
right we don't even say
[__] on here that much yeah I'm sorry
it's okay
um so get it so let's get through
because yeah I know you have a show now
that is very sexually involved it's very
it's it's in the sexual world right yes
it's in the industry it's in the end as
the folks say in the industry so I want
to see how do we get there so what has
sex been like in your life up to this
point you're in college you're not
really digging it uh then you get the
job at Barstool where does sex kind of
play and have you been watching
pornography growing up have you been
like um were you exposed to some type of
violent you know drawings of people
[__] what happened
um you know I've always I've always been
a horny guy I'd say like one of my
favorite stories my mom always tells she
tells everybody that she tells everybody
that growing up she'd always just tell
the story that she fell asleep one day
when I was about three four years old we
watched Titanic she woke up and I was
just
rewinding that scene that's what she
always says wow I don't remember it
because I was three or four years old
but she always says it and I I don't
think she's a lion lady
grown woman watches that with a
four-year-old seriously I think she just
wanted to watch the [__] Jack and
Rose fight over that door but I mean I
was there for it I just I was just
attracted to it like there's a photo I
have of me I gotta send to you guys you
want to put up here when you put it out
it's like there's just a picture of me
in Vegas when I'm maybe 10 years old and
there's just a big pair of [__]
like ceramic tits behind me wearing like
a fat Tony's yacht shirt I've just
always enjoyed it I've my dad's caught
me going through the Playboys in the
Attic before yeah yeah I mean those are
all those not only are those awesome
just because there's like full bushes
and
naked women in there just seeing the ads
and all Playboys are awesome yeah it's
cool it's not like it's always a guy
smoking or something yeah it's a nice
drawing of a car in the background it's
never like that it's all cigarette ads
yeah it is all cigarette ads yeah it's
just hits It's just cigarette ads and
then like here's here's our interview
with Rising Steve Jobs and one of them I
have yeah it's really really cool the
ads are awesome but um yeah and then I
think the show just led me to um
I've never been absurdly into porn but
now if you're climbing up a ladder now
here's so you went up into the attic to
look at it yes sir so there is something
now because I used to bike about five
miles right I'd go to my friend's house
and his daddy had a little bit of
pornography hidden in the uh in the
toilet in the bathroom
so I'd get in there and I'd lock myself
in there and I'd be in there for like 40
minutes on a Sunday morning at their
house and it was like going to church
yeah the only person taking like a 40
minute [__] at that point was somebody
who had like Ebola or somebody who had
like you know some disease you got in
the war Taco Bell yeah yeah something
heavy yeah
so I was you know at some point they
knew I was in there jerking off you know
um but I I noticed at that point looking
back I would bike five miles on a Sunday
morning to masturbate at someone's house
and I didn't know that well I think
that's well worth it honestly I mean I
grew up in an age luckily enough for we
didn't always have the internet like if
we had our phones I think the first time
I jerked the first time I came I didn't
even think I jerked off I think it just
happened naturally oh wow I always
remember which kind of sucks there
wasn't even a face involved it was um
remember that movie sex drive let's pull
it out it was the unrated movie sex
drive and the actress at the end was
Katrina Bowden wonderful actress but she
didn't go topless in the movies so they
literally panned down to like a decoy
pair of tits and that's the first thing
they ever came to she came with fake
tits I came to just always an unless
they're real just not even contreed
about it so it was just an unnamed pair
of tits I don't know who the first tit I
came to was if if you look on the IMDB
of the movie will it let you know maybe
I've never done it doubt I might look at
that later yeah because there was they
like show her face and then she takes
her top off and it's a unknown pair of
tits sex drive great movie though Zach
can look that oh you know who's in there
my uh Seth Green is in it yep and also
Clark Duke who I love yes very funny
dude
um Zach can look that up in the
background and see if those tits if he's
yeah it should be Katrina bad in his
tits in the unrated version yeah that
was always a fun thing the unrated
versions yeah it was something that came
out you know I remember looking uh I
remember being
um
finding some pornography and liquor at
the same time and I was drinking and
looking at it and I didn't know what was
going on and I was on the top of a
shelving unit and then uh ejaculated and
uh
fell down to the ground just blacked out
it was just overdrive very worst things
to happen honestly it was overdrive that
sounds awesome God it was good that
sounds like a home run but then there's
something after that where it's like
everything kind of changes you know you
just feel like some you know
then you start to just abuse yourself
first to get semen out of you yeah yeah
I mean I'm not gonna sit here and say
and sugar coated there when once I
figured out what was happening there
it happens a lot like like a goddamn
professional ball player good it's the
best then iPhones
iPods infinite
infinite I could only imagine like you
were saying growing up you and me too I
was looking at the magazines mine
probably I would say my main source of
tits though growing up was like unrated
American Pie movies yeah I would say you
ever see American Pipe big house
a lot of tits that I would I would
venture to Guess that has the most
topless
um women in a movie ever
it's an astonishing amount of tits in
this movie astonishing
I've seen this more times than I've seen
farscope yeah
you think you've been to church more or
seen this more
dude I don't go to church that often
but you had to go growing up we would go
occasionally we would go occasionally I
would maybe go every maybe a few times a
year maybe 10 times a year
but I really haven't gone
depends actually Mike high school we
would go to church for school but it
would be in the basketball court yeah
and the pastor would come in is going to
church I don't know we had assembly
sometime we had this beautiful
um Miss McManus I think she was our
principal there I don't know or she
could have just been like a real angry
lesbian that was at the school I didn't
you know you didn't know sometimes you
know
and um
but she they would always have that
assembly you know and it was like we're
having an assembly you know and it would
be like
and it was always like kids were
urinating on the they had like the spec
the heaters in the like the old heaters
it was an old building from like the
1930s that we all went to middle school
in and they had people were pissing on
the heaters and it would steam up the
whole bathroom
so then people would play like ghost
baby and stuff like that and things like
you know and uh Planet of the Apes all
that [__] in the bathroom because it was
all just piss steam you know oh dude so
she had to have a meeting and say no
more pissing on the things you know and
um it was crazy telling children that
because kids were in there just and
that'll make probably want to make them
do it more sounds like a lose lose for
everybody though the second you heard
about it if you were doing it you're
like we gotta get the fighter fight yeah
yeah and we had a janitor this dude Mr
Larry and he would piss over you into
the [__] urine while you're in there
he was like the BJ Armstrong a piss yeah
this guy was it was Unreal bro how he
could [__] hit it every time right
over your body like you could literally
look up and see it going over you like
the um what's that thing in St Louis the
uh golden arch the golden arch yes sir
so you were under this madness he was
peeing out he would be from behind you
feels like a secret there's like a yeah
he was like a [__] Savant or whatever
you know giant no he wasn't a giant I
mean he was a giant to us we were in
fifth and sixth grade but he was
probably I bet five nine interesting
black though so we had that you know
yeah yeah he had that damn well endowed
so get us so all right so you're
cruising through life
you're at now did you finally did you
get to sex before you got to
uh Barstool I did not wow I'll tell you
that I'll I'll say it I don't mind I
mean yeah look I mean I'm doing fine now
so I don't really mind talking about it
yeah look I mean I wouldn't I always I
wouldn't say I'm like I wouldn't say I
was popular per se like my friends were
like no like normal kids they always had
fun looking like I said still best
friends at all no more great guys but um
yeah never never dabbled in yeah it's
all right and so were you nervous that I
mean dude I remember I mean
uh yeah I was it was always so
nerve-wracking I mean were you nervous
when you got in when you when you did
you know it was gonna happen was it like
a
all right this is it it's a girl I'm
dating this is a big night or was it
just kind of like here it goes it was a
girl I was talking to for a little bit
and we had done stuff before that we
hadn't done the the whole nine yeah I
think it was going on to a good concert
so
um what concert you remember
people are gonna uh it was Billy Joel
and he's my favorite artist ever
actually so that's another that's a nice
uh bro if you could make up to a woman
after Billy Joel
what's better than that nothing
literally nothing that's really good
yeah it was a Billy Joel con it sounds
rare I feel like dude yeah I'm in the
80s yeah
all right Lobby it was it's a cool story
it was like Billy Billy Joel concert it
was beautiful I mean what I actually
never said that so it was a Billy Joel
concert everyone a lot of people if you
if you know me remotely you don't I love
Billy Joel so yeah who doesn't maybe now
people maybe not people know why
ah seeds from an inside restaurant and
some sex it's a good Duo and do you go
back home did you go to a hotel or motel
no it was at her apartment yeah God now
you're venturing in enemy territory I'm
wondering was it more fun to have sex on
home turf or on a way Turf I'm an away
game guy I love away games I love away
games I mean me and Caleb also travel a
lot that's a good point uh I'm a big fan
of away games I mean I I love sex but I
just I enjoy like I've said this many
times on only stands like I just enjoy I
enjoy the chase of it a lot so I love
doing the away game stuff yeah and and
I'm not gonna lie to you every time I go
to bars at home
I don't get like the same Vibe with
women I just don't talk to women the
same I don't know why
I feel like they they like me less
there's something about an away game
this is the Lord of an away game well
yeah
they can get you at the local store
because you're there 100 but when you're
just passing through town when you're
like you're a
um you're a commodity you're you know
you're like when the train would come
through and head like uh rib eyes on it
you know and you got a bunch of Brothers
just beating the [__] out of each other
trying to get to a real because you you
know but if you grow up right next to
rib eye factory plus right next to Peter
lugers it's not gonna be the same so
yeah I mean definitely the way game guy
there's no doubt about it
you make love to the woman when you
leave there
this was it did this things feel
different I'm trying to take myself back
to them it felt pretty damn good I
really remember actually I actually got
a text from my buddy that said his
manager at one of his uh at the firm he
works for in the city just said I saw
Glennie walking down the street looking
absolutely disheveled
and I said yeah yeah that's what it says
dude makes absolute sense
put two or two together did you tell
your mom after no
I did not
I don't even know if I told my friends
honestly
this is the way they're gonna find out
it's just interesting and I'm trying to
remember who I told you I also didn't
tell her so this might be the way she
finds out too if she watches this that's
beautiful man
which might be embarrassing so I haven't
talked to her in a while which would be
awkward but whatever
dude I made love behind a Tiffany Lane
by they used to have a bowling alley in
our town called Tiffany lanes over there
was that out uh Outdoors it was Outdoors
out back wow I'm just still never done
the whole public sex type of thing it
was it was it was it was you know I
almost always so I've always had so like
it's gotten better now but I had so much
pressure like in interacting with women
yes sir that it's like a lot of like
nerves going on oh 100 and imagine
you're like imagine somebody's
electrocuting you and you still have to
play Jenga you know yeah that's kind of
how it is I think if you're really
nervous and trying to do it get her get
a good erection yeah I mean there's no
two ways about it too I'll be the first
two minutes like I just said it
accomplishes a lot of like as I guess
I've grown more at work I've been
confidence is risen and now it's fine
yeah but a while ago was like it was I
totally get it it's [__] scary sex is
girls are scary especially in Europe
once again I'm no Tom Hanks I'm trying
to say Tom Hanks I'm no Tom Cruise yeah
like it's it's an intimidating thing for
the fellas I'm no [__] Lonnie Hanks
you know I know
you're in shape though the In-Shape guys
got it easy all you got to do is be in
shape but also here's one issue thicker
guys think that just a guy is in shape
like dude yeah that's true to me you
have a six-pack
in my in my world you might as well be
Fabio
oh that's hilarious man yeah dude
there's just I mean it well it's
interesting once sex is introduced to
and I'm talking a lot about sex today
because I want to eventually we're gonna
talk about your show yes and um and sex
is a driving force and a lot of young
men's lives you know I think about that
it shapes kind of like once you start to
learn about sex it's interesting because
then your interests like some of them
start to disappear a little bit or
dissipate because that takes up like 50
percent of the brain you're a preacher
of The Choir God I cannot tell you I
remember I remember before I lost said
virginity I would grab my friends and
they would always be like trying to give
up girls and I would just tell them
dudes like let's just hang out at the
bar talk a little bit
now I kind of get it yeah yeah
yeah dude because but then also you're
like how's this weiner gonna fit in the
vagina like there's so many little
things if you don't have a role model to
tell you about sex you know yeah did
your dad tell you anything about sex not
really no kind of just kind of swung it
yeah
oh man I mean I I you learn from the
streets otherwise you learn from the
sandwich Shoppers you know I'm saying
you learn from this you know the subway
you learn from the you know if we don't
learn from a parent or something yeah we
had to so your dad didn't learn you no I
kind of just want I gotta just won it
and Wang it I thought I was I don't I
don't know if she knew or not I don't
think she did so I think that means I
passed the test kind of let's get called
I didn't get it is this your first time
yeah it's actually the the first night I
when I was with her I May went down
downtown and she said that she was like
oh you're [__] good at this I said
wow you know I appreciate that it's one
of my first few times that's cool man
yeah
yeah it's also nerve-wracking row back
then I you know we had some calls a
while back about
if it would be better if family if uh in
some tribes you know there's tribes in
Africa there's tribes in
Europe where they a older sibling or a
father teaches the child how to
masturbate really
because then you're learning it you're
learning sex from like a it's part of a
familial thing it's not as like this
taboo thing that like you know you know
uh Little Richard shows you in the woods
one day you know and he's you know
coming on a lizard or whatever and a
masturbation you need to be taught I
kind of just thought it was pretty
primal
but I think you if you have a sibling
that teaches you and takes you through
it or you have a parent that takes you
through it then some I guess there's
some cultures were to believe that
that's the way to do it you know we've
had a lot of callers call in and say
yeah my brother taught me how to do it
sir which is interesting it would be I'm
sure I think I would have been nice to
have a guide but trust me I I didn't
need one I figured out how to jerk off
yeah yeah it was it was that first
summer was a it was a tough one would
you do any cool tricks with your hands
to make it different when you would
masturbate everything no I mean my left
arm sucks dude I can't really I don't
think I could jerk off with this thing
if I tried oh wow I'm a very right hand
dominant like even growing up playing
baseball sometimes not that I'm a
[__] Babe Ruth but growing up playing
baseball until I was like 14 like I'm a
lefty and that's because you're swinging
this way your right hand is coming
through pulling the bat around I don't
know how right he's follow through with
her left arm my left arm is so dead I
don't know why but this thing is trash
yeah am I like if I had to lose this
limb I wouldn't even mind really I'd do
nothing with this don't jerk off with it
don't eat with it I do nothing with it
God yeah so I'm very right hand
dominance I'm really just focusing on
the right hand jerk off but don't you
ever it's almost like sometimes when you
want to like I'll use like my language
learning app or something it's like no
they'll do the same thing I'll mess with
my left hand it's like I just want to
like give my you know
you know to try to be not like artsy but
to try to like you know
learn a new language I guess or switch
up a category
on pornography on the I'm in the realm
in the industry oh yeah
so well that kind of brings us to where
we are now so you do
um you have a show called only stands
yes sir only stands so are you kind of
like a male
you consider yourself like a like a kind
of a like a male do you consider
yourself like a male sex symbol or like
a journalist no it's funny because I
would never consider myself a sex symbol
ever because I'm not a sex symbol in the
slightest it'll be cool to be considered
a sectionable though I feel like you are
though I feel like you're because I
think of you or I see you now yeah I
mean I know some of your world and and I
know that you love sports you work in
Barstool Sports I know you're involved
in that universe but now I see you
around you know sexy women and you guys
are you know talking about sex yeah it's
been fun I mean I definitely consider
myself a journalist I'm I'm a one of the
only few only fans journalists in the
world try to try to keep the the
journalist interviewee
relationship fine and they always say
I'm a journalist so I I enjoy it it's so
much fun I mean I love beautiful women I
love talking to beautiful women I think
they're very fun to talk to and the way
that most only fans Queens are they like
a lot of podcasts I don't know even if I
do podcasts it's where they get to just
talk about random things I try to just
talk about random things and fun things
as much as possible yeah yeah and then
obviously there's a lot of sex talk
because it's fun to just read off hey
just had a 10 guy blow bang
right you had Whitney on
how windy on recently she was amazing I
loved her she was so cool she was so
funny she's amazing she gave me a b
costume one night what's that mean I
think I don't know
she
I was at the comedy store and she gave
me a beekeeper's uniform oh really for
no reason interesting do you still have
it yeah still in my truck in my truck I
don't know so I gotta give her a buzz
and check on her but um yeah she was
great she was like the first time I was
really like Star Struck by somebody I've
been watching roasts since I was 15 so I
was very cool oh yeah but yeah yeah
super cool that's when it comes on and
that's talking oven roast so yeah dude
sorry
Angelo Angela White it was great we just
had her on she was amazing and now
Angela White tell me about her so you
interview a lot of women that do only
fans right so now that only fans has
kind of took over the Indian industry
since covid covert had a huge up climb
because everyone was inside so you just
did only fans so now all the porn stars
do only fans as well and Angela White is
like
the [__] Ken Griffey Jr porn oh
really she's amazing and um so she's on
her own only fan so we had her on and
she was just I got drinks with her on
Sunday she is just the nicest one of my
the most interesting humans I met in my
life she's amazing yeah like an amazing
she the nicest person I've ever met like
we had Whitney on we had Winnie on and
we talked about uh how Angela White did
a Two Broke Girls porn parody and Woody
made two bro girls so we watched the
clip of Angela White and then like made
that into a clip for the show and when
he texted me I said a glimp [__] that's
so funny but we got to get some of the
clips of the show in there and within a
second I texted Angela White she
immediately responded back talked to the
producer talked to the director got it
all done in 10 minutes wow she's just a
she's a she's an angel Angela White is
an angel
you know it is interesting a lot of like
uh a lot of strippers and uh uh
pornograph pornography women yes sir and
Men maybe two I don't know I don't ever
look at
you know I'm kind of I don't look at the
wiener when I look at pornography ooh I
do really like I enjoy a good [__]
porn and you look at the wiener or you
look at the mouth
I think I look at the mouth going up and
down and the wieners there yeah but I
know if you don't want to see the wind
or your brain won't see you yeah I
definitely see it I definitely see it I
enjoy [__] porn I mean there but
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of different porns out there my personal
favorite is bachelorette party porn oh
yeah yeah you ever watched dancing bear
do dense Bears is company I don't know
what I don't know if they're even still
in business but um it'll just be these
25 horny housewives on a bachelorette
party the dancing bear rolls and it's a
male stripper with a huge bear mask on I
need to roam us around they'll blow oh
wow yeah I don't know why I think the
idea of a housewife doing that is kind
of erotic to me that's why I like the
door it's like the new age door-to-door
salesman kind of kind of yeah and then
there's her being intrigued by that
really blowman kind of oh really blow
what a [__] Pawn that is is that
Death of a Salesman
I think it was huh yeah so now when you
but now tell me this so how does that
start to influence your sex world
because look I try to stay out for
pornography right I respect it I've seen
it all
I know what they're doing
I
but my problem is I start to then think
of sex only in like the frames and the
things you see on pornography right yeah
so it's like I'll think of like and I
notice this even like with a lot of
women now it's like you hook up and it's
just like little thing it's almost like
you just go through these vignettes that
are on pornography doesn't even feel
like a lot about like physical touch
anymore 100 and a lot of guests have
said that that porn makes people
delusional about how sex actually is not
every time you're having sex as a girl
going to be screaming at the top of her
lungs that's just not gonna happen yeah
so they always say stuff like that but
me oh a lot of times if you're having
sex or girls don't even be screaming at
the top of a low murmur or saying
anything talking like this oh dude yeah
oh I'm the side dude during sex I am the
silence dude I know I was saying that
too on an episode a few minutes ago some
girls were talking about what what you
should do when you're getting like head
or something I don't really I don't say
anything I say yeah sometimes or
something yeah someone one of the girls
was saying like um just be like oh
you're you're a good little [__] Pat her
head I'm like I'm not [__] saying
that [__] dude
it's crazy it's crazy so I I just like
to stay quiet yeah I think I would yeah
I would say yeah
um
I would say oh we gotta get out of here
sometimes I'll say stuff like that I
think I A lot of times feel like
something about to get caught
so and I think that comes from having
had sex outdoors I think that comes from
you know I Gotta Be You know I got bj'd
be Hannah
um thin tree when I was young so people
could see the sides but not the actual
yeah it wasn't a redwood so it was Tiny
oh yeah I mean it was um so you were
doing some public sex dude just the way
it happened you know I know I didn't
have a place where somebody really could
come over to my place and uh a lot of
poor people you know the early sex is
outdoors interesting but yeah I totally
get I think I'm sure a lot of people
there's many many many outdoor videos on
only fans people definitely enjoy the
thrill of being outdoor I guess and I
guess viewers enjoy the thrill of is
this person gonna get caught that's a
huge thing have you seen the compilation
of bee stings during outdoor porn I have
not but maybe that's a correlation of
why when he comes he's got you a d
costume
full circle I love that
um
so has that effect but is that hard
though because if you're a guy who grew
up with not a ton of sex right or you
know because a lot which is most guys
yeah you know I mean I had one sex
person uh two sex persons women's until
High uh college right yeah if you had a
bunch and if you had a lot of sex in
high school you're a [__] oh you're
gross bro you're a rapist douche I think
right like if you had a lot of sex in
high school dude you're a loser yeah
dude if you got chicks in high school
dork yeah you're a sick [__] homie [__]
off uh yeah no the show it's not that
doesn't make it that different for me
honestly if anything it's it's I've
noticed that girl normal girls think I'm
like [__] every guest they say you
have all these hot women on your show
and I'm like we're just doing a podcast
like that's really it at the end of the
day but I've had just a you know I've
had women here and when they I don't you
know I've had women anytime a woman's
around a lot of times you don't want
them to leave you know it's like you get
attracted to women is it hard to
separate work you know oh yeah
it depends honestly it depends on the
girl like there's definitely girls I've
had on my show that that we clearly Vibe
a little bit and there's some that I
haven't and maybe some of them will get
dinner afterwards like managed to like
at dinner that night a few gun drinks
but afterwards but like nothing crazy
can you legally make love to the world
or can you legally date them is that
even a legal thing I guess you could I
don't see why not I mean I I haven't
wouldn't I think either way it would be
it would be unprofessional yeah if I
said maybe did it that night of the
podcast which I never have but I think I
think that would be that would be a
towing a line
I would say maybe if let's say I did a
podcast and one of them lived in LA in
the next month I was in LA and she was
like oh let's get drinks I would say and
then if we we five once again never
happened once again if that happened I
guess that would be okay right yeah
that's two consenting adults yeah
yeah so I'm not and watching some of you
watch this stuff like do you have to
watch porn to prepare for your guests
then like that has to be sometimes
because so a lot of most of my guests
there's like porn girls and only fans
girls the only most of them are only
fans girls so not all of them do porn
that's a good point and that's not all
the people sorry there's a lot that
there's a lot that are just some some
don't even post like their boobs some
Lily don't even post boobs and make
astronomical amount of money so my guess
vary from porn full-blown porn stars
like Angela White two girls that
literally don't even posts their boobs
to Whitney Comics who does comedy only
fans so it's it's whatever but I mean if
that thing has got them freaking hammers
on her boy yeah respond respect but um
she got them [__] time baby because
actually she said it she knows it but um
yeah so really just depends depends on
the guest I'll definitely I'll
definitely tune in I gotta subscribe for
science for research the day of but
they're doing everything they come in
like how do you even I don't jerk off
every time I look at it you know
but it's so hard not to they the
algorithm is set where you're gonna
skeet at the end buddy that's true but
then again it's also it depends on what
they're posting on their only fans not
everybody's posting the the that's the
peak the peak of what you want to see
what's your only fans bill every month
um
I think I subscribed to like 28 accounts
but obviously a lot of them are free so
a lot of girls do free accounts and then
they'll charge in the DMS for a whole
bunch of money for the nudity or whatnot
so I don't know like I buy everything in
the DMs I would say the bill a month
maybe 100 200 bucks it really then not
many girls do too many
um
high prices a lot of free
and then I really and I don't buy much
content from my guests I literally just
look at it it sounds stupid but
journalist I'll just look at like when
you subscribe to them the DM that comes
up
what they're offering how much they're
offering stuff for I've also found like
a great way to prepare for the guests to
go through their Twitters like they're
just they always treat fun stuff Tick
Tock stuff yeah a lot of dating
questions like talk about dating but um
no actually the important itself I don't
watch too much of the porn
I also I also do that work because I
can't watch too much porn at work but
then against work but it does there's
something that if you're watching porn
at work there's something that feels
like you are
not doing well would you agree with that
yeah if you're if you're tuned into if
you're tuned into uh if you're on
xhamster at the job site it's probably
not the best you never want to log into
xHamster from nine to five yeah but yeah
I mean hey it happens there there's
there's some porn girls with some only
fans girls and and honestly they're all
great I'm a mess of fan of all
interesting man so you so you're able to
separate the work and the sex a hundred
percent like a big thing too is uh like
the first episode we did we had this
girl Genie aximon and she offered me to
be you know only fans video with her
that's what I saw you and Caleb talking
about when Caleb was in here last time
she offered for me to be in an only fans
video with her meeting me and her having
sex
and I don't know just doesn't need to
consider it no I said no instantly I
just I don't really see the I really
first off I told my mom I want to make a
sex tape ever which I'll Oblige by okay
and number two I like I said earlier I
really don't have a
I want to do a Chase if you're just
offering me sex I'm not interested kind
of I want I want to be able to
get it properly I like the whole idea of
that so there's some romantic there's
your romantic kind of in a way I would
say so yeah I want to know I could charm
a lady yeah like there's there's times
I'll be out of the book like there's
times I've been at a bar obviously
I'll do whatever and whatever but when
you're at a bar and a girl just says yes
to hey you want to go back
that's just as good right that's just as
good okay so sometimes that that'll buy
that a block that'll oblige it that'll
oblige the it yeah just follow him do
they go she said yes we're good here she
said yes I'm happy I'm happy with it
right I should yeah but on a regular but
if you have your wits about you and you
haven't drank in a day or two and you're
thinking of yourself you know I'd like
to meet a woman I'd like to you know be
a man of stature kind of to quote John
Mulaney yeah I do I just love talking to
women yeah I love women well now see I
do you think it's increased your ability
to speak to women on the regular or do
you think it you still kind of
compartmentalize it in one in the other
like your show and then meeting a woman
in the wild I do think I've always I
think I've always been good at talking
to women
but I think it was more of in a in a
friend zone Type of Way definitely in a
frenzel type way now I think I talk to
women and at least they like look at me
as remotely some sort of a sexual object
which is nice but I would I would say
that I was actually watching a Chris
Rock uh stand up um not even stand if he
was on Fallon I think like last week
actually and he was saying he was trying
to get with Rihanna once he got single
and Rihanna didn't even look at him as a
sexual lodger she like Uncle lies to him
he said yeah that's almost how I kind of
felt like it was back in the day now I
feel like at least
I'm not being I'm being sexualized okay
so now you at least you have some
sexuality yeah I think I gotta I got a
fighting chance I got I was going to
battle without a sword now I at least
have a sword right
which I'll take right you were never
Babe Ruth but now you're at least Ruth
yeah or Baby Ruth anybody I'll just be
I'll be a solid 250 hitter 20 home runs
a year 80 RBIs I'm happy with that yeah
I don't need to be Babe Ruth but now I'm
performing with the battle I at least
got a sword I got a hammer I got
something with me right
Interesting Man yeah I just kind of been
curious what that world's like um it's a
fun world yeah I'm sure well look I mean
you get to talk to women we get excited
when we get women in here yeah then then
really they're all very very cool
they're cool chicks yeah I have some
close friends uh that are uh only fans
or do only fans
um it's kind of become a way that
women
uh
can take the you know control of the
sexual industry if they're involved in
any form of the sexual industry or even
just like an artistic element of sex
yeah it doesn't even honestly it doesn't
need to be sex I know girls who do the
cooking content on there right right I
guess sexualized something 100 and then
if you're a good looking chick like
there's just so many that just makes so
much money and like I said really don't
even post nudity now what about world
what suggestions do you have say that
there's women that don't that don't
think of themselves as sexy women right
they don't think of themselves they see
like a you know like one of these blonde
kind of uh
Hermione Granger or whatever and you
know in a two-piece or whatever and
they're like I can't be that right how
do they create and only fans that could
be marketable well that's what a lot of
people say I mean they're only from the
one of the beautiful things about only
fans is so many girls there's a market
for everything I've learned yeah
literally a market for everything so if
you're not feeling maybe like a maybe
like Bo Derek they're still probably
guys that are in the market for what for
what you're selling yeah and that's just
completely a fact I mean one of my
favorite questions to ask every guest
they'll ever guess this is what is your
most interesting odd subscriber request
you've come across from your subscribers
and they all say the most ridiculous
things there's there's people out there
that will like you for you no matter
what there's there's a category for
everybody I think and that that's I've
learned that yes do you think it's
healthy for women to do only fans do you
have do you ever do you gain any thought
on it by getting to meet a lot of these
ladies and uh uh have you what do you
think about that I think it's it's an
interesting it's interesting and it
depends on the way they think about
themselves kind of like if there's uh
there's a lot of girls that will
complain to me but I can't find a
boyfriend because they're doing only
fans or something
and I'll I'll tell them all the time
like I say this all the time there was a
point in in my career at Barstool where
so many comments about me were like very
very mean and like I just thought to
myself I'm not gonna like I'm just gonna
stop reading them because I I don't I
don't mean this to sound the wrong way
but I think like
probably if there's like some guy and
these are also people that are
commenting super muted about me on
Twitter so that guy probably is more mad
at himself I guess he doesn't like
himself and he's just deflecting that
onto me to be mean to me so I I'm
telling the girls that I'm I always tell
them even off camera I'm telling them if
someone is being mean to you calling you
let's say a [__] about for being an
only fans they're probably just jealous
that they can't do what you do that they
don't yeah have that opportunity to do
what you do because let me tell you the
the money they make and what they do
it's it's unbelievable only fans it's a
crazy platform and if you and anyone
that would make fun of them for doing
that I just think is crazy it's crazy
they're they're Geniuses I often say
they're Geniuses and they're literally
geniuses
well I mean it's like yeah people will
call you a [__] they will call you a
fat they will call you a
piss baby or whatever
but a lot of that is on them I've never
I've often said this I've never
wanted to talk [__] about somebody that
I didn't care about if that makes sense
that you yeah you didn't have some like
you know there wasn't some ink Intrigue
yes if there's like I'll I'll often see
like maybe maybe a douchey looking dude
with a really hot girlfriend he's tatted
up but oh my God this [__] guy yeah
like the only fans girls is one thing I
say they love to [__] the ink guys the
only fans uptick is huge for the tattoo
Community really they're all banging
tattooed guys wow yeah it's crazy what
is that you think a lot of tattooed guys
dude you'd be shocked and I'll say this
a tattooed girl
pasty skin you know what I'm saying that
Boo Radley skin you're out on a girl's
on tattoo lady you're out on a girl
tattoo like a full sleeve you don't find
it attractive oh yeah yeah I do I mean I
like that you know if there's a pasty
like like uh
you know some girl who's just like oh
dang I'm
oh you know [__] I'm ready yeah they're
they're intimidating gals but the dudes
they the girls love tattooed guys every
guy they're [__] is they got they're
basically their dick is tattooed we can
also tattoo crazy stuff around your
wiener that makes it seem awesome you
could tattoo like a large dick you know
four inches ahead you know like like
like uh you know stop you know turn
around here for more dude have you ever
seen the show Gigolos by any chance on
Showtime oh it's fantastic it's great
television it was like a live it was
basically a I think a fake reality show
that was on Showtime I found it after
Dark One Night in high school and just
these four Gigolos hanging out in Vegas
and [__] chicks doing their job
one of the guys on that show Nick Hawk
he had a tattoo where he was basically
almost like Venom from the Spider-Man
movies was taking over half his body so
like all this was tattooed just black
like if anyone's taking over him and it
went all the way down the tip of his
dick like a little your shaft was
tattooed
full shaft wow yeah
you know a lot of men that are secretly
gay will ask their wife to get like
um
um butt cheeks tattooed around their
vagina really yeah
I guess I guess it kind of makes sense
you know yeah a vagina tattoo sounds
pretty rough though this one was worse
than dick tattoo addicted to it over a
fact you got to stay hard for or they'll
have them write like this as a bud and
like point at it or something you know
anyway I'm just it's not down there it's
up there yeah it's just interesting
um what are some like moments like
working with like as a sidekick with
Caleb what has it been like has there
been some unique moments like he told us
about a time when you guys got to hang
out with Aaron Rodgers all day
um because yeah we only see that
oh that's you guys yeah that's my phone
background
wow dude I mean like I can't I've
watched that clip bunch of times from
the show but like Caleb said he he was
just the coolest the coolest person I've
probably ever come in contact with he
was amazing and he was as Caleb said he
was like old school cool it almost felt
like you were hanging out with Frank
Sinatra he just had that Vibe about him
and he was just the coolest guy and just
amazing we hung out with him drank for
hours and could not have been nicer and
just he was a joy but yeah we've had
some weird some weird ones I mean in the
last year I would say the two craziest
things that we've done thanks to Caleb
and your Sunday conversation I guess I
[__] sang Rockstar with Nickelback on
stage that was sick and then I want to
be a rock star and um yeah no I mean the
biggest one which like I still don't
even let my brain think about it is
[__] I'm gonna Drew Bible on Sunday
conversation and kissed you by more oh
that's right you did huh [__] Drew
Barrymore did they make you do anything
before like did they test your mouth did
they swab you did they like Frisk your
jowls or whatever for anything so Drew
walked in and I'm I've always been a
massive Drew Barrymore fan probably my
favorite actor so I'm obsessed with you
about anymore oh yeah she's like my hot
Macaulay culin me and my mom have been
watching Wedding Singer together since I
was a baby I love to buy more yeah just
hearing her voice first it was I Heard a
Voice I was so Starstruck and then
Kaylen so Caleb hands me this thing he
says we wrote a quick script at the end
we're gonna talk to Drew about it she
walks in you say Okay Drew you and Glenn
you're gonna do a quick skit at the end
you're gonna pretend you guys are at a
restaurant in Australia because I was
dressing an Australian man and then
saying um Drew says oh no I don't want
to eat what I want is you
and then it's like go in for a kiss and
we obviously tell her before you don't
have you guys don't have to kiss but
just like get up and like pretend to go
in for a kiss but do whatever you want
then we're doing it this part got cut
we're shooting the whole time and the
whole time sitting there saying what's
going to happen what's gonna happen here
and before I forgot what Caleb Esther
but she was basically saying in her
acting career she's never wanted to fake
things and then I'm telling myself does
this mean this has been Drew Barrymore's
about to kiss me right now
and the way she was talking she kept
saying I should never fakes things in
acting
and we started reading it and as you see
there she got up out of her chair and
then came up and sat still like right in
front of me and then said in the line
then she went in for a kiss and then we
kissed and I just said to myself as
though I just [__] kissed Drew
Barrymore that's
otherworldly true Barrymore's that's
your prayers Moors upper echelons
[__] Drew Barrymore dude and then we
[__] Caleb told her well not not that
we just did this for fun we had to we
had as you see in the clip too we had to
get a shot of us both going in directly
so we had to get the cameras closer so
we did we had to shoot again and she did
it again oh my God I kissed her twice
now the second time you have to feel
like you're in like a little
relationship I did I said to myself am I
about to go to dinner would you rather
more am I about am I about to date Drew
Barrymore I would be so down Daydream
Barrymore like so so down with AJ
Barrymore
oh man and I know I was pretty excited
when she posted on Instagram I think she
posted that clip and she could tagged me
before Caleb no big deal she seems
really cool she seems like she's gotten
into the uh
like the podcast social media space like
she gets it you know yeah I think
there's some people that are like
getting real like really late to the
train of like being okay with doing
social media she was so nice and I I
will say which is kind of shocking now
we've never really had a mean guest per
se I think as the guests get bigger and
bigger I'm noticing there's a reason why
they get why they're so big and I think
it's because they're just like good
people and everyone is just so nice
there's really no one that's me not that
it won't be me but like they're all just
exceedingly nice like overbearingly nice
she was amazing like Drake was so nice
to us Rogers was so nice to us yeah he
told us about that what about
um who was one that you didn't get to
spend time with
so there's a there's a difference
between a lot of them will be well like
Caleb said on when he was on here like
well they'll book it our book of people
will book it and then they'll just be in
and out like Ice Cube walked in walked
out
um
Kodak Black walked in and walked out
then people we've hung out with and we
hung out with
Rogers a lot Drake took us to dinner
um who were some other good ones but you
just broed down with let's see true Drew
left after but I mean it was true she's
allowed to leave Stephen a left after
what are some other good hangs we had
Michael Irvin hung out with us for a
little bit but yeah he seems really
entertaining I would like to see uh Paul
uh um I would like to see on there
um Joey B would be good oh Joe borrow
yeah yeah I think he'd be great I'm my
current uh dream one I think is probably
Larry David yeah I think Larry Dave
would not only be I got a few guests are
mean to me which is fine I don't really
care I think Larry David would both be
mean to me and Caleb and he would just
kind of take it over which I think would
be hilarious yeah and I think kind of my
other I know he's going sadly going
through some stuff right now but I think
Jamie Foxx would be really funny I think
Jerry Fox would be a great one so though
I guess those are my current white
whales yeah I think uh who else I would
love to have on here is um uh Quaid
Randy Quaid oh I think it'll be amazing
you guys Dustin Poirier would be great
on your show uh Kayla might try to get
him next year
um Randy Quaid where'd you get that from
he's just like he's just so I I just I
don't know I just wonder about his
journey what he's been up to he's such
like this iconic actor
um and played such an iconic character
in uh National Lampoon I don't know I
think I would just be in would he be
your acting World
um I will
no I'd probably go Julia Roberts first
respect who doesn't love Julia Roberts
ah dude if I oh if she only knew what I
would love to if I just I just want to
sit on a porch with her somewhere and
watch her read something and watch
something like a sweet tea with her for
some reason I could see her enjoying a
sweet tea I don't think she let me sit
that close to her but that would be fine
I picture a porch I picture a large
porch rocking chairs back and forth like
maybe the distance we're at right now
actually Roberts would be a cool one I I
really I really would say for myself I
think in the actual film Drew Bremer
would have been my pick I I do believe
that I mean obviously like Sandler would
be cool oh yeah Sandler Channing Tatum I
think would be good
um who else uh but yeah my top right now
is like Larry David Jamie Foxx Sandler
yeah I'll be my top three I met Trump at
the
um ufcs oh yeah this is like the last
week in Miami right yeah how was that it
was interesting man I mean you're like
you know I mean I love being at UFC
right so it's like for me it is
literally it's like being like you ever
been
um
baptized or whatever yeah
don't recall it but yeah I mean I I feel
like though I've never been to UFC but
just the the vibe of it how they just
have everybody there it just seems like
one big I guess for you obviously just
an interesting VIP party it's a who's
it's almost like uh like the Oscars for
cool guys if that makes sense it feels
like it's the who's who of actually who
has some [__] nuts you know that's
what it feels like a little bit and I'm
not even saying me but it feels like you
know that's the energy that Dana has you
know yes um
you know I got to talk to him for like
maybe 12 minutes just even talk about
like some work stuff and like uh uh you
know and he's had a lot of great success
in what he was sharing and stuff like
that and so that was really cool how to
work with advertisers some business
stuff but then like
Kid Rock is there he rolls in with Trump
you know we're in like Dana White's
dress green room right and I've been
trying to do some like
um maybe some Social Media stuff with
UFC so it was my first time like doing
some of that but I get to be backstage
by the fighters you know it's like
you're getting baptized but right when
you come up two dudes are beating the
[__] out of each other right yeah so
it's like that bro and uh yeah there's
just so much going on you turn this way
somebody said because they've you know
their stuff they're going through defeat
and Agony this way somebody's a hero
this way they're you know they somebody
just Flatline this way there's like some
uh of a ring model trying on a new top
this way there's uh Joe burrow in uh the
boastable yeah Justin was there I think
yeah I saw a punch people there this way
there's
um just some lady that's there that has
the biggest tits ever right and it's
like she has some jack dude he's
literally carrying one of her tits
probably tatted up oh he was so tired of
course he was and she can't even carry
both tits so she's balanced and he's
literally carrying the other
so it just there's so much going on but
then Trump rolled in and um
it was just interesting you know you got
I never met a president before and I'd
never met Donald Trump before now don't
take us the wrong way but do you did he
know who you were no he didn't his son
know uh knows me Donald Jr and um I
don't know if his other son Eric knew or
not but it was just interesting you know
yeah Mike him and Mike Tyson rolled it
at the same time I'm assuming him he's
going to this event now everybody's
gonna just be there and he's gonna have
to say kind of make it seem like he
knows you no matter who he's talking to
because he where he is everybody is I
guess of notoriety now as a as a person
that gets to go to those things do you
would you say you're more excited going
into the night to see the fights or to
just spectacle of it oh I think the
fights uh for sure yeah I've never been
to one where you're that close up that
close up that seems like kind of a
once you go there you can't sit can't
sit up high yeah I mean I think I I
would just to see the fights but it
definitely I felt real fortunate you
know uh to go and yeah you're just
seeing these guys and like when they're
putting it on the line you know like I
think in a lot of ways comedians
um strippers
um
Fighters yes sir you know anybody that
does something that puts themselves out
there they're you're all trying to gain
like to be seen in some way you know
some you're all using something you have
to attract
uh to get acceptance kind of in a way
100 I mean that's I mean I've never done
setup that's one thing I always tell
myself if I ever go to a comedy club or
my friends send a clip of somebody doing
stand up I will never say anything bad
if bad about anybody in the sound if you
have the balls to get up there all power
to you yeah I think
all power to you yeah that's how I am
about Fighters I think because it's just
so like I always had a tough time
defending myself when I was a kid and so
you know I didn't feel like I had
protection and [__] so you get to see
these guys who are doing it and then and
find out the different reasons that
they're doing it and it's all to me it's
real fascinating you're gonna do a lot
of fights growing up no
I got into maybe six fights oh you know
that's hot
and uh we had a lot of brothers in the
area too so every now and then a brother
will flare up out of nowhere you know
and you'll be in a fight but um
but yeah
but it was it was it was interesting and
Trump's just like you're good how are
you doing you're doing good in president
mode yeah you're great you're doing
great your parents are doing good yeah
it was just he's so like yeah he said
you know I was like my dad's been dead
for like 22 years and he's like but
before that he was doing great
like you know what he was he was doing
great before that but actually I kind of
like I was like you know what I
appreciate that that was worth the price
of admission that was better than any
fight you're gonna see uh but yeah he's
yeah he's just funny but it was fun
though man it was just that was that was
a spectacle and uh yeah just to get to
meet like Joe Bro and then to get to
listen to Dana and get to just be in the
see all the fans it was great
um what else let's get into some news
what do we got Zachy
this is the story we were talking about
earlier there's a teacher in Oregon
who's uh on leave right now because he
assigned the students in class to write
their sexual fantasy for for a report
did he not check with anybody else
before he did this and you can uh read
it for yourself right here
let me zoom in there you can you read it
yeah for those students who are absent
you'll write a short story or a
paragraph or two stories of sexual
fantasy that will have no penetration of
any kind or oral sex so no way of
passing an ICD you will choose three
items romantic music candles massage oil
feather or boa flavored syrup to use
your story your story should show that
you can show uh how your go by receiving
love and affection without having sex
I I don't think that's that bad right
it's only worth 10 points it says 10
points for yeah I wonder how much of the
whole semester though but that's not
horrible I mean you know there is no I
guess if you have to say no penetration
oral sex then it's not that great if
you're in school but that sounds kind of
fun yeah look I think
40 years ago I could see them doing this
in school this sounds like something
you'd read out of the 70s that happened
you know like when like it was more like
free love I think and it was like you
know tell us a you know write us a soft
core romance novel unless they've been
reading something like this in school I
mean it's interesting because all kids
are thinking about at this age or what a
lot of them were occupied by is sexual
thoughts and energy fact
100 percent
like you have people there's some kids
you Pat them on the back hard enough and
they will ejaculate
yeah you know and so
you it's like that's just what's going
on in their bodies so I wonder if there
is good ways to do
to create like positive
sexual uh works that you're doing in
school if there is going to be one I
mean I guess it's that there's there's
no there's no penetration in the world
you could do a romantic a romantic tune
maybe some of the weekend or something
like that that's always fun and then
yeah they mentioned the flavored syrup
the foods maybe they could throw in some
oysters they didn't mention oysters
there they can throw in some oysters
yeah it's not a bad idea just maybe a
home date get some oysters shuck them
yourselves get horny through that throw
on the tunes that could be a paragraph
or two for that class yeah
yeah I think yeah that would be
interesting and now I'll tell you this
everybody's gonna show up to school to
write to re-listen to other peoples
but is it gonna lead to
people you know uh sending each other
you know some people doing semen on a
piece of paper and folding it up and you
know giving it somewhere you know that
raw shark tank are they going to come
from hearing the stories in class right
it maybe if there's a way to tell it
properly I would imagine you can't
really tell it properly though in school
I hope that's also not a project you're
reading out loud this sounds like a
teacher only
but if the teacher only is reading it to
me that has hella per Vibes dude and
then how do you know who's getting a
name who's getting a d
yeah what differentiates that one yeah
and if anybody gets a d dude that guy's
going to jail yeah that's maybe the most
beautiful girl in class is walking out
with an A plus and I'm walking in there
with the D it's not a good look even
though my grammar may have been better
dude I remember somebody threatened a
Spanish teacher in our bathroom and
threatened to beat the [__] out of him
if they didn't get a b and he gave him a
b oh really
I wonder how often that was I wonder how
often stuff like that actually works
with uh teachers my High School uh my
school there was like um we had tests at
the end of every trimester that was
worth about 30 of our grade and then the
average of those three trimesters was
half of it then the other half was comps
and the end of your chest would be 50 of
our grade yeah so my buddy literally at
the end of senior year or junior year
whenever you're applying to colleges he
was so I was better meth he took it to a
new level he would be he would truly
average I think his average was like a
45. he's an idiot one of my best friends
oh yeah my great voice great singer one
of my best friends but he was really bad
in math great singer you know great
singer now two times seven it is nine
he's got a great he sings like grunge
90s but um yeah and uh he legitimately
wrote a paragraph to the teacher at the
end on the last um thing saying I really
don't want to go to Community College
like please for love God to ask me you
got passed wow yeah there's something
about it look there's a way sometimes
you know to get things done and some
people are able to do that I think in
this instance man I I feel like this is
a something you do in college I feel
like it's a little risque to do it in
High School uh
I think it would be fine probably but
then also if I'm a high school kid dude
I'm jerking off dude you know the second
I get this assignment I'm your the whole
time I'm doing it you know if a girl if
I try to write homework with a friend
I'm gonna try you know I also show up
this is ninth period class not a first
period class I want to go directly home
after this Not Afraid imagine getting
this first period you got to hear some
erotica at 9 00 a.m yeah yeah little
bathroom break yeah you just roll
another Hall with a mouthful that this
has got to be nice period it's got to be
last period dude you have a mouth full
of [__] Sweet Tarts you're just
rocked up and then everyone's probably
walking around the hallway saying who
had the best sex story of the day and
everyone's exchanging sex stories so
this seems to be a ninth period type of
thing wow that's interesting but then
also it's like who could become a
graphic novelist you know and this is
where they start and this is where they
learn that they have that ability
um what else we got Zach well you
mentioned the weekend this is a big deal
a AI generated a fake song of uh Drake
in the weekend which is uh
I guess a lot of people the industry are
very concerned by this obviously because
I I can't play the song but if you hear
it it's pretty
it sounds like it's an actual track from
these guys really so someone has said AI
create a fake weekend uh Drake collab
yes wow and you gotta shut AR down dude
it's freaking me out okay so the people
are just saying hey make this video make
this song it can do it it can I can
confirm like I actually I don't know I
don't know if he wants me to say this
because we didn't put it in but I don't
know why it wouldn't matter I don't know
if you showed you this either but for
Drake Caleb made used AI to make a drake
something conversation song and then we
played it for him
and he like enjoyed it like it sounded
like Drake and it was a full song that
Caleb wrote
and it was a full Drake song it was like
a legit rat so Caleb wrote it though so
AI didn't write it no Caleb wrote it but
like on whatever the technology was it
was literally sounded like Drake doing a
whole rap there was a beat rap it was
like Sunday conversation shout out Caleb
Blanding like all that so what could we
put in right now could we put something
in Ai No we could put in like a prompt
like a writing prompt could we put like
have uh
Glennie Bowles give a wedding speech you
could do something like that yeah the
chat GPT thing that yeah that you can
I've experienced this for the first time
like last month yeah we think about a
lot about this stuff it's just like I
find that the stuff you get a lot of
times it just feels like a dumb version
of something
it feels like kind of a rip-off of the
AI stuff of whatever you're creating
yeah if I say can I get a Glenny balls
like restaurant review or whatever it's
like there should be no personality
right a goddamn computer doing it so I I
definitely get it but I mean if you
wanna I feel like if you're writing in
work toad you can probably pull it off
like we know when people start off work
emails saying kind regards what's a good
point or hey all stuff like that maybe
people like that like people working for
tax firms can get away with it but right
do this do these taxes maybe yeah like a
wedding speech right now if we're gonna
have me do a wedding speech I wanna want
to imagine actually I'm gonna be the
best man in the wedding in October for
the first time so I gotta give a speech
I've been thinking about it I don't want
to personalize it to the couple you know
right I want to make it make it homey
let's see what it would be
do you want to read it I'll read it yeah
yeah I mean read some yeah
okay I'm sorry what's up everybody it's
your boy Glenny balls today is a special
day because we're here to celebrate the
love between these two amazing people I
feel honored to be standing here in
front of all of you to give this speech
but let me tell you I am a little
nervous I mean I'm used to being in
front of cameras before but this is a
whole different ball game first of all I
want to congratulate the happy couple
you guys are awesome and I'm so happy
for you both I remember when you first
told me about YouTube and I could just
tell right away that you were meant to
be together you just had this connection
this spark that's undeniable and now
here you are about to embark on this
amazing journey together as husband and
wife
this to me this what does it feel like
to you so far it feels like a cookie
cutter wedding a wedding speech right
and then it goes I have to admit when I
was asked to get this speech I wasn't
sure what to say I mean what do you say
at a wedding but then I realized it's
actually pretty simple you just have to
speak from the heart and that's exactly
what I'm gonna do yes keeps going yeah
it sounds like somebody trying to get
through an essay that has like the
original like four good sentences as
someone that has to do with best man
speech in October I might use this and
just like add a little bit like find
different things I can put in there
because that does sound pretty damn good
it's a good point and now that's one
thing about this life you know it's like
um
uh it's doing one in your voice now and
the voice of Theo Von because I I think
the more search someone has online the
better it's going to be at writing one
okay I'll read the beginning go back
what's up y'all it's your boy theovan in
the house uh it's cap dude that's
horrible I gotta say I'm honored to be
here today celebrating the union of
these two beautiful people y'all know
I've been to some wild weddings in my
time but this one Takes the Cake and
speaking of cake I hope there's going to
be some good eats up in here tonight
Jesus Christ hell yeah brother I think I
switched it made me sound like a
freaking black guy
I mean I appreciate that dude I love
that you know I don't know if you hit
like you know shift B and freaking game
people send this stuff up I can say
people fans send in AI Theo Von voice
every day everything yeah this just
seems to me it's fine but it's just like
if you want
but you're all right that it gives you
the Bare Bones of something it feels
like it'll give us a good a good talking
point and listen to talking points and I
I literally may use that it's a nice
it's a nice Bare Bones way to start if I
get married I'll do it for vows I think
you now this could definitely be a lot
for if you're doing papers in college if
you're doing something for the boss like
or you know some pretty generic stuff
where all you're doing is just kind of
getting checking a box anyway where it
should be literally sound computerized
it's about to sound computerized right
100 that's a good call for anybody
that's still having to do like just
basic stuff that doesn't even really
matter but it does because it's checking
a box I feel like that could probably be
really something of use to you but then
more than ever having some sort of
personality is going to be of value yeah
I mean there's no reason why if I was
doing a normal let's say I do a report
to a higher up after a good week of work
why don't I just put in there great week
of work for everybody on the team with
Melissa Kelsey and Bill and then just
copy and paste it personalized with
myself bing bing boom send it out I'm
done oh
every Civil War paper from school was
gonna be done here it's like any War any
history papers it's a wrap yeah does it
does it do like um stuff like that can
you can you just write can I have a 300
word summary of the Civil War yeah whoa
they should do the sexual fantasy prompt
to it and have it right for the kids see
now if you're on there though and let's
say someone on there is on there in
Wisconsin and types in the same exact
thing you do are you getting the same
exact answer well let yes that's the
problem okay let's do the sexual thing
for the children
and let and that's
somebody's gonna clip that out that's
gonna be Bane of my existence let's do
the sexual thing with the children I'll
go down with you oh no we just [__]
bro it's so hard to talk anymore because
they're just people just making
everything out of any moment
I have to manually write it because it's
a screen grab I can't like copy and
paste it so check back on this towards
the end give us another topic and then
we'll get back to it at the end
what else happened what's something big
in the headlines
um oh wasn't I saw that there's that
Chinese Sun did you see that article
somewhere Zach
you know what I'm talking about yeah
Chinese artificial sun uh breaks new
world record by burning hot plasma for
nearly seven minutes now this is
interesting that's some Spider-Man 2
type [__] yeah doc Hawk was doing get us
to the beginning of his act
all right yes you read that correctly
the country has a huge device China has
a huge device that has been able to
generate a plasma temperature of 160
million degrees Celsius for 20 seconds
in the past
right so that's as hot as the sun right
I would say so that does not sound good
if not it's still really hot but that's
20 seconds in the past can you zoom up
Zoom down sorry
um according to the global times the
East performed a high power stable
steady state long pulse High confinement
mode plasma operation for a whopping 703
seconds now that's like six minutes yeah
holy [__] bro can you imagine that's how
long it takes me to drive to the [__]
Deli and stuff dude that's [__]
insane yeah that's enough time for you
to drive to a deli 106 minutes so
imagine say it's like dude if China
makes a fake Sun I mean that's that's
the biggest weapon on the planet by far
obviously unreal you give me fake Sun
against nuclear weapon I'm going fake
selling what if the nuclear weapon
theoretically used to sit and wouldn't
it just disintegrate into the fake Zone
well dude imagine they send a fake son
to fight or a real son
Marvel's out of business strike back
with the moon no no the moon I think is
Loki yeah dog no that's disrespect but
he's already I've heard you know
here we're going back though people said
a lot of things about him but
um fire always beats ice which is a
problem for us and they're they're first
to the jump on fire
but imagine though you're already
working all day in China and now they're
like guess what the day's over we got
another day
sucks back
people be like what the [__] but it's
not big but it's not big enough to go to
go to the whole country it's gonna be
like in your town specifically just two
extra hours per Town your beijing's just
getting [__] up tonight with my son
and then it goes over to I don't even
know where bro imagine all the school
kids are like you are my sunshine my
only sunshine dude he's gonna change all
the songs dude they can't have another
song that would be unfair the Itsy Bitsy
Spider went up those water spout
yeah two times but now spiders me anyway
tough day for owls in China huh yeah
yeah dude owls dude out of business bro
it's a rat what are some other nocturnal
animals I don't know many but dude if
they have a fake [__] son Zach yeah
it's kind of that's kind of a that's
kind of a Checkmate I don't know what's
bigger than a check made of a fake sun
which I guess theoretically he's a real
son but when you can write but when you
can create your your your people to work
20 when you have like no night
when you can have people work all day
and then have a second group of people
so your GDP is gonna double so you're
you're saying this zone is more of it's
going to get more people to work I'm
thinking the sun itself just having a
second sun is a weapon in itself
yeah I mean you could say like they
don't want us to get any sleep that's
their first it's like we all go to bed
and they're like guess what Nevada
here's a son at night you're like oh
[__] here comes the China I'm
envisioning this is just like a burning
thing if they're just throwing a ball of
160 million temperature Celsius at us
we're kind of [__]
I don't know if you can throw a sun
well I think you send it yeah in fact
it's a guess right it's gonna be
sponsored by happy Dad I bet Maybe I
have no idea
I have the fantasy if you want to read
it oh all right so I I Abridged it
slightly but it's just read a short
story and a paragraph or two no
penetration of any kind or oral sex
choose three items to use
so if anyone wants to read it
all right
she walked dimly she walked through the
dimly lit room and this is a child sorry
and I just want to preface I'm sorry to
interrupt you this is a child your
student writing this to you you were the
substitute teacher or you are the
teacher yes and you've sent you've had
the kids write this paper she walked
into the dimly lit room wearing nothing
but a silk robe and high heels as she
approached the bed she reached into her
pocket and pulled out a small vibrating
egg she turned it on and placed it on
her on her [__] moaning on her [__] as
the pleasure pulls through her body next
she picked up a feather and trailed it
lightly over her skin shivering out the
sensation finally she grabbed a bottle
of warm oil and poured it over her
b-r-e-a-s-t-s rubbing it in with her
hands she closed her eyes and
surrendered to the sensations lost in
her own pleasure oh uh sir I need to go
to the restroom dick dude I couldn't
believe they dropped that four little
word in there bro that immediate you
know how many kids out with the hall
pass dude that was that was also that
was erotic GPT is horny yeah that was
that AI guy is horny that was way more
erotic than I think a lot of kids are
turning in but you know what it's almost
kind of nice about this the feather
lightly over the skin you know that is
this is something that I kind of miss I
miss reading in the pornography mod
magazine you would read the art because
all you had was an image so you had to
read to make the image come to life you
know yeah the future I will say the few
times I've no I haven't been recently
but back in the day I was a bit of
Reddit jerk off guy and Reddit there was
a um there's like a whole thing called
Gone Wild on Reddit where people just
like post nudes non-stop but I remember
there was a gone wild
um I forgot what it was called maybe
gone wild story or something like that
people just write like erotic stories
they kind of get you going they rev you
up damn oh yeah well there's something
yeah you read it you're like because you
know you have to get to the next
sentence so your brain know you have to
use your brain literally to get there
each word is another little moment and
it's keeping you dude I mean I remember
I would go to the library in our town
and they had those um
those art books from like the 1500s or
something oh yeah with the
with the rubenesque women oh yeah by a
stream a little angel above her
absolutely you know when she's having a
little uh little cut of hair a little
cut of apple or something and she just
gotta you know if that's your supplier I
got high on that Supply gosh yeah some
of her kid is even heading for the
riverbank you know she's right on that
River Bank where it's like damn that
River's about to get that tit I'm
jealous dude but yeah I mean that's a
big thing with I guess sex if you're not
actually having sex imagination of it is
such a big deal and I guess through
erotic stories you're just popping off
with imagination well that's kind of
what I think at the actual video
pornography kills a lot of times and
it's not a judgment against anybody that
I mean I've I've had addiction to it in
my life
um but it does kill that part of your
imagination the imagination is what
activates your cells kind of I love them
I I will actually say that people may
think I'm lying here I would say
probably half the time I masturbate I
think I'm going imagination
yeah Amen brother I'm [__] yeah
salute I enjoy the imagination uh uh
masturbate I do oh dude I used to take
that book and I've discussed this before
and I would literally put a wiener in
the book in the library book
in the library and close the book on it
as hard as I could that that's what got
you going
well just there was just something about
just the pressure of it and I would well
it was so hard to find it because
usually they had a picture of like a
bring a breast breast oh I guess it's
the closest you could get to to the
beautiful lady from foreign
that's very fair that's very very fair
please so in your brain you're just
you're just getting that as close as
possible to the queen oh
I would actually love to see one of
these photos yeah there we go oh look at
that lady
but do by Riverbank oh yeah she's good
actually that's pretty awesome she looks
cute
there we go there's a couple of them you
know how long the artists are sitting
there doing this for I don't know
but I definitely uh
and if she just sitting there topless
the whole time yeah yep in Dubai
Riverbank if you can
well that's a party in the top left
yeah now that's some angels in the woods
Sometimes some of that was hard to find
a breast in because you just I want the
immediate breasts right by the river
you know because I think the river also
offered a way you felt like you could
Escape once again in public yeah public
point I want to see the tit and go
I want to be on my way
um but yeah I would just close my body
into that book because
it was the only pornography that we had
it was all what we had yeah earlier when
you mentioning that you would go five
miles to get to get your eyes it's
important yeah that's all you got that's
that's fair and that was after that came
out so this was the first thing that I
was at the libraries man when you would
see it
and it was good man it was the best dude
there's nothing like I've said many
times on on uh only stands there's not
many better things just seeing some
boobs they're just awesome yeah it's
really just eases the soul eases the
mind it's like finding a mystery like
finding the Killer and who'd done it
just see what they look like it's like
Mother Nature's nuts dude some good tits
It's really the best it really is
nothing nothing no dispute
um do you get a lot of invites to
restaurants and stuff do people do that
a lot I feel like probably being a more
rubenesque male that a lot of people
like come here come eat here you'll love
this but also having an appreciation for
food that's what I should say yeah
there's there's definitely sorry I'm not
trying to no dude I don't care I'm I'm
wearing my larger gentleman no worries
but I would say um yeah I do get a good
amount of food invites I don't always
want to go though because there are some
there are sometimes where you get
invited somewhere it's like an awkward
scenario like you don't you don't know
I'm assuming you go through the same
thing where you don't know
um you don't know exactly what's going
to be presented to you so I don't I
don't do it all too often but there's
definitely been times like
uh a guy who've seen like YouTube videos
actually I was out in Manhattan on
Friday and the owner of Peter lugers I
saw he saw many years ago come in
whenever you want like that I'll do but
there's if there's a random place that I
I don't know other people then maybe I
won't like yesterday The Cheese Shop uh
the guy Dom my friend knew so those are
experiences that are that are fun
obviously if it's like verified I also
don't know if a lot of restaurants I
don't know if the food's good because
most of the people with the Enemy or
people are employees of the restaurant
sort of they're obviously going to say
their food's good right what if the
food's not actually good and then yeah
it's awkward
what um
what uh do you think you'll ever end up
maybe doing a food show or something
like that it would kind of fit huh maybe
I would love to that's like that's that
I guess that would kind of be the goal I
just I like food TV I really enjoy it I
uh I mean I used to do a burger show at
work for quite a while there was a good
period of like maybe three years where I
was just not doing that great at work
and I was always doing a burger show and
I enjoyed it but I probably did I don't
think I was that good at describing the
burgers I would like to see now that I'm
so much more comfortable in front of the
camera how I would redo it and just
making more back I would just put it
down I basically do like a day of pizza
review
but with Burgers I'm definitely was just
wildly less successful obviously
but if you ever did it on food chart I
like to do way more like high more
higher produced maybe trying more
different Cuisines that I haven't tried
yeah a lot of intrigue in that like
Indian food I would like to dive into
maybe some Thai oh yeah I'm really
enjoying Mediterranean food yeah stuff
like that just expanding the old palate
so I mean I would definitely do a food
show at the time for the time they were
doing ice cream and only fans but maybe
down the road I do love food yeah you
got a pallet for it man and that's nice
because some people their tongue they
really it's a it's got more uh Intel in
it yeah when I got when I had covered I
couldn't taste anything that kind of
stung yeah that was horrible
did you um
who might have talked about everything
huh we've been here a while three hours
yeah
um
dude have you ever been to a live taping
oven only fans or pornography shoot dude
I have not there's is that something you
would do or not I think I don't really
see the Allure there are some girls I
know in LA right now they're actually
trying to get me to go to one tomorrow
but I gotta leave I gotta leave tomorrow
right so I'm not gonna go but then he
tells me to come with so much fun I
don't really see the the alert of it
like if I'm not doing the [__] I
don't why do I want to see somebody else
do it yeah so I don't really see the
lore there and I'm assuming it's awkward
I mean I've for every porn person I've
talked to they make it seem like it's a
pretty professional setting it doesn't
sound fun to go to
there's no wanting in my brain to want
to go to a porn set I would I don't
wanna I like to see how the cookies
crumbled in a kitchen
maybe not on the porn set I'll enjoy the
porn I'll need to see how it's made yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel you man
um I don't think the actors want us
there either
yeah I think it's probably yeah I don't
know if you're sitting over there I
don't want to be like say you're chewing
gum or something and they look over and
they're like you know
then what yeah they're getting you're
talking in their shop talking in their
backswing yeah or just like can you blow
a [__] shot oh never want to blow a [__]
shot then you gotta restart
oh are you cheer when somebody
ejaculates see that would be kind of
cool actually yeah there's a live
audience like there that's the thing
though if you wanted to go bills when
somebody yeah yeah someone jumps over a
table I mean you guys want to see I mean
I bet they not that I bet I would
guarantee you porn companies that live
audiences or porns
they would pack it out
that's a great Point huh that could be
what's next yeah you never know you
never know what's next um thanks for
stopping into this cheese shop bro oh
dude thank you very much for having me
this was a great time I appreciate it
man I had a great time thank you so much
for hanging out and just good to get to
spend time with you man
um yeah I know we both love Caleb and
getting to spend time around him and
um yeah
yeah he's talking about him hope he
stays alive too same dude I I think I
hope all three of us stay alive that
would suck if we didn't and if we die
soon I would this clip
kind of pop off I guess so hey but yeah
yeah I guess you know if it happens if
it happens dude uh I love you guys yeah
I love you guys and um I guess my
parents can have the money I have I
don't [__] know whatever yeah yeah
how's your mother doing is she good yeah
she's hanging yeah she's still smoking
or not yeah trying to get her off the
off the off the old smoking dude she
loves to smoke happens though I don't
know that's the only thing I've ever
done I've never never smoked cigarettes
yeah
my friends say the drunk cigarette that
was super uh super enticing I've never
done it um
yeah it was all it was all pretty good
when I had them yeah
um Glennie balls thanks for coming in
man dude thank you again appreciate it
it's great thanks brother
[Music]
gonna take